wait
to keep going over there we go there we
go
um if you could lead us in the Pledge of
Allegiance please
so we have four bills to hear today
these are
um abs and any
surprises way out of left field these
are our four Senate bills for the
session so once we complete our public
hearings today
um that should be it and then I think
will will probably want to review what
we do today and then use that to
schedule hopefully a single executive
session and hopefully in plenty of time
so we're not up against any deadlines
um so do you want to take a roll call
all right let's um really quickly
because I see we're missing a lot of
folks obviously Mr chair Mr Vice chair
is here
um rep avaloni
rep Prout
I don't think he's here
rep love
rep Boyd s Boyd
Rhett Mason
rep Cole come
here rep Drago
rip Granger
and Brian to love you and Ben's oh Ben
is here sorry representative Broody here
representative Cahill
Roberta representative diesel vestro
nope
um representative Susie here
representative Bouchard
representative Mackenzie president and
representative Leclerc Le Claire
and representative Schultz is here and
that's it thank you
all right thank you very much and
without further Ado we will open the
public hearing on Senate Bill 42
relative to overpayment of unemployment
con compensation and uh Senator Whitley
is the prime sponsor and will introduce
the bill good morning thank you uh good
morning sorry for the rush we are in the
middle of session right now so I'm in
two places at one time if you can't tell
uh for the record my name is Becky
Whitley I'm honored to represent Senate
District 15 which includes the wonderful
communities of Concord Penacook
Hopkinton and Beau so I'm uh happy to
introduce today Senate bill 42.
um this is an issue uh that the Senate
has discussed for many years and this
product that you have before you is
really a refined version of what we had
been talking about in the senate for a
few years so simply put the bill
prohibits the state from charging
interest in the settlement of over
overpaid State unemployment Congress
compensation where fraud is not an issue
and like I said this is a very targeted
um set of piece of policy and it's also
uh consistent with existing federal
policy so the state is already
prohibited from collecting interest on
overpaid Federal compensation and in in
the federal case that's regardless of
fraud so this is a more New Hampshire
targeted solution we're only looking for
the prohibition on the collection of
interests where fraud is not an issue
to put this into context around the
around this country 22 states do not
charge interest on state unemployment
New Hampshire also does not charge
interest on any other benefit so I think
this is
um important policy because we don't
want to be singling out this particular
benefit to charge interest on so I'm
sure this committee is well aware that
covid related job losses in New
Hampshire included new folks to the
unemployment Arena gig workers business
owners those staying home for dependent
care issues or exposure to the IRS by
the time an overpayment is discovered in
most cases that money is already spent
on rent food Child Care things like that
so the data is also showing us that our
service and healthcare workers our
sectors are being more impacted right
the majority of folks holding these jobs
are women so we know that women are
being disproportionately impacted by uh
the unemployment situation and so
therefore in uh that's another important
policy that we're talking about today
towards equity
in the past couple years New Hampshire
women lost more jobs than men they have
taken on more caregiving
responsibilities and served as the
majority of essential workers on the
front lines of the covet pandemic so uh
the Senate felt very clearly this past
unanimously in
um Senate Edna and again on the floor
that applying interest on state
unemployment overpayments is really
overly punitive and it's particularly
cruel and and really unnecessary as we
are rebuilding our Workforce coming out
of the pandemic
um I'm happy to take any questions but I
certainly am not the expert on this
topic and there are some folks behind me
that can speak more to those the stories
of perhaps those who are on unemployment
and of course the Department of Labor
can also speak specifically to this
issue so thank you for having me this
morning and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you very much are the
questions
representative love
thank you Mr chair thank you senator for
taking my question do you know what the
state of New Hampshire prosecutes uh
fraud cases in this case uh uh so you I
think that's a question for the
Department of Labor you know this bill
is really just targeted at that
collection of Interest so certainly he
he could speak um I think the deputy
Commissioners here can speak to their
efforts on fraud issues but again this
bill is specifically targeted at
prohibiting interest in cases where
fraud is not an issue thank you
other questions
thank you very much for your testing
thank you good to see you all
so I only have one additional card put
in
and I think
I'll hold you to to last
and and have you come up next
if
it doesn't look like there can be
anybody else but
if you know of anybody that's outside
and it hasn't put in a card please
encourage them to do so
um
testifying now is Dawn McKinney she's
from New Hampshire legal assistance and
she is in support of the bill
for the opportunity to speak with you
this morning my name is Don McKinney I'm
the policy director at New Hampshire
legal assistance
you I do not have written copies or
written testimony this morning you
received an email from my colleague
Steve Tower last night I believe
um expressing our support for this bill
we've been representing clients we're a
non-profit Law Firm that represents
low-income and elderly clients across
the state and we we worked um
heavily representing folks during the
pandemic related to unemployment and we
support this bill and urge you to vote
ought to pass
we are one of New Hampshire's one of
only 17 states which collects interest
on non-fraud overpayments
um that interest is it a rate of one
percent monthly 12 percent for a year
and the sorry I just realized I can't
read without my with my glasses on
anymore
um
so this is a situation where folks have
not committed fraud they have made
erroneously overpaid received
erroneously overpaid
um benefits
um
and a lot of that can be attributed to
during the pandemic you know things were
changing really quickly and um
there are many honest mistakes made in
completing the paperwork and confusion
and misunderstandings about the
requirements and so
um and many of the folks who made these
claims also have other difficulties
whether it's you know language access or
various disabilities and so we would
just really encourage you to pass this
bill and I would defer any kind of more
substantive questions to the Deputy
Commissioner but
um we're supportive
all right thank you very much are there
questions
clerk hi
um I'm not sure if
um you can answer this or maybe this is
for the Deputy Commissioner but do we do
you have a sense of like what causes
these overpayments is it the something I
mean if it's not fraud that implies that
the person who would be charged interest
currently
um didn't do anything wrong right so
what are the what is the reason for the
over payments like before covet because
I understand this was an issue before
can I have a second question
I could I I'm sure that the Deputy
Commissioner could expand on this much
more in much more detail but um I think
generally particularly I can speak to
during the pandemic it was the confusion
with creating with um kind of evolving
it was an evolving situation right with
the pandemic and then also with the
unemployment I think the department did
um amazing work to get the benefits out
as quickly as possible and in the
process I think some folks
you know made mistakes when they were
completing the paperwork and the
requirements were kind of evolving and
things like that so just I would say
honest mistakes around you know
reporting
second question thank you Mr chair
um do we have a sense of how many people
that owe interest at this point is there
a rough number and what the average
person
is charged in interest you know on an
average case basis
um I unfortunately don't have that data
I imagine the Deputy Commissioner might
but I can't speak for him either so I
apologize
further questions representative Cahill
thank you and thank you for taking the
question I I will follow up with the
Deputy Commissioner but my understanding
is that he's had the capability to waive
uh in these cases and has done so uh I
think it
uh wherever wherever possible so I
certainly support the bill and uh and I
think we're going to pass this rather
easily but I think that has been the
past and when they find that there is a
mistake whether the department made a
mistake or changing the rules they don't
go after the uh the innocent uh claimant
um I would let the Deputy Commissioner
respond to that I I know that there is
the opportunity to apply for waivers but
um I don't know to what like what
distinctions there are or anything like
that I'm not I'm not personally a case
Handler so I don't want to misspeak
thank you yep
further questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
and as I said my last card is from
Deputy Commissioner labors of the New
Hampshire employment security
foreign
good morning members of the committee
just for the record Richard Labor's
Deputy Commissioner New Hampshire
Department of Employment Security
um the department is neutral on this
bill so the department takes uh no
position and what I was hoping to do was
just provide a little
um further explanation with regard to
types of overpayments or improper
payments payments that should not have
been made to a person because they are
subsequently found ineligible and also
just try to put it into context so
fraud overpayments are off the table
right with this bill this bill is not
dealing with those instances in which
someone is found to have willfully made
misstatements to the department in order
to collect benefits to answer
representative Love's question with
regard to criminal treatment of some of
those the department pursues
unemployment fraud very aggressively so
we have a partnership with the criminal
Bureau at the Department of Justice we
actually fund a full-time prosecutor
that handles unemployment fraud they
focus a hundred percent of their
attention on earnings related fraud so
instances where someone files for
unemployment benefits is found eligible
so they had a qualifying separation they
were unemployed through no fault of
their own subsequent to that they then
find new employment or return to Old
employment and don't report that to the
department despite being asked that on
their weekly claim so they're collecting
unemployment benefits and they're
receiving regular wages from new
employment and they don't report it we
always find out about those situations
and we try to stress that to individuals
when they come in in the early part of
their claim but yet people still will
engage in that type of behavior so in a
in an effort to try to deter that from
going ahead in the future we've had this
relationship with the Attorney General's
office since 2015 I believe I actually
have an interview at 11 30 over there
with
[Music]
um
uh Sean Gill the chief of staff for the
Attorney General to interview people for
Phil our prosecutor position because our
prosecutor just left to go to another
position in state government so we want
to fill that quickly so it's a strong
partnership when individuals engages and
engage in egregious behavior that they
they continue to file for unemployment
despite going back to work and it's
situations that's clearly greed and not
need those individuals are prosecuted
most of those cases settle because the
evidence is so is so strong against the
individual and in more cases than not
those individuals do actual jail time so
they have stand committed time they
spend in some cases it might be a few
days other cases depending on the length
of their fraud could be a few weeks but
they spend time in prison and we make
sure to sing that from the rooftops not
because we're proud of it but we want to
know for other individuals in our role
of protecting the trust fund to make
sure that those tax payments are
available for people that are rightfully
collecting and need them that we take
that role very seriously and that
they're a very serious repercussions for
engaging in that type of behavior so we
have press releases that are on poster
board in our offices we remind
individuals of that when they come in
for their workshop at their beginning of
their unemployment claim
um so we're we're very aggressive with
that but not to confuse things here this
bill does has nothing to do with
unemployment fraud so unemployment fraud
if you're found to have engaged in that
activity you're found overpaid either
criminally or civilly that debt carries
statutory interest at one percent a
month and this bill wouldn't touch that
so the types of improper payments that
this bill would impact fall into one of
two buckets so these are non-fraud
overpayments and these are situations
where the individual is either
determined to be at fault in creating
the situation where they were paid and
they should not have been or they are
without fault so the easier situation to
describe is when they're without fault
that's when the department screws up it
happens
and during the pandemic as Dawn was just
explaining what the federal government
changing rules seemingly every week that
happens more than it would in regular
times but what we do in those situations
with New Hampshire Law requires in those
situations is that if you are without
fault in creating an overpayment so your
paid benefits which you should not have
been and it's not your fault it's either
the Department's fault or perhaps an
employer's fault you do not have to
repay those benefits so interest never
accrues on those types of improperly
paid benefits you'll receive a
determination from the Department it
will say you are ineligible because and
we'll explain that and then it will go
on to say that because you are without
fault you do not have to repay those
benefits so there's no debt that the
individual who is paid when they
shouldn't have and it is not their fault
there is no debt that they have to the
department
and obviously no interest accruing
because there's no debt so that's the
easier bucket
and I can I can explain the other bucket
and then maybe that will answer the
question and then we can come back to it
or you're in control not me so I can
answer the question now too
okay
um so the other types of improper
improperly paid benefits that are
non-fraud are situations where the
individual is determined to be at fault
so they were found eligible they're
they're paid weekly benefits and
um is then determined that information
that they provided that was material to
finding them eligible was inaccurate or
misleading or perhaps information that
they did not provide should have been
provided and would have been reasonable
to have been provided so if that is
determined that individual would be
found ineligible for the period of time
that they were paid and those conditions
were applicable they would then be
explained in that determination that
they were with fault and why and then
they would be told that they have to
repay the benefit benefits which they
were paid that they shouldn't have
because they were determined to be at
fault in those benefits being paid now
each and every one of those
determinations the individual can file
an appeal so the appeal rights are right
on that so they have the full
administrative
appeals remedies available to them so if
they disagree with that determination
they can appeal it they can have a
hearing before a hearing officer and
they can have an opportunity to further
make their argument as to why something
is wrong with that determination
interest does not accrue if they file an
appeal or challenge a determination
finding them overpaid there's no debt
the determination is not considered
final at that point
when they have exhausted their Appeals
and the debt is then final that is when
they have an overpayment they have a
debt to the department for which they
would need to repay because they are
with fault in creating it now the first
60 days upon that debt becoming final
are interest free so the individual has
those 60 days to repay that debt
um without accruing any interest
after that 60-day period interest
accrues at that one percent per month
per the section of 282a that requires
interest to be applied
um now the department does not
um simply require individuals to repay
those debts all at once in an
unreasonable fashion we do as many any
other agency does as the court does when
individuals have have debts we engage in
a process with those individuals we they
fill out Financial affidavits certifying
as to income and expenses and we
determine what their ability to pay is
so we engage in that process in-house at
the department now so it's those
individuals that have been not
determined to have gauged in fraud
because again our fraud resources are
really focused on those unreported
earnings type of situations
um and they are determined to have been
at fault in causing the overpayment and
those are the only individuals that are
required to repay those those benefits
and those are the only individuals that
accrue interest
um if they carry that debt Beyond 60
days now some situations that you know
beyond the situations during the
pandemic for a non-fraud overpayment are
not the situations that we have now so
during the pandemic you're dealing with
a lot of self-employed individuals who
were unable to substantiate their
business activity in the and the federal
government required that in order to
collect benefits that was a a common
situation to be a non-fraud overpayment
but those situations don't exist now
self-employed individuals don't have
eligibility for regular State
unemployment benefits so the situations
that we see now are the ones that you
would expect effect so
the circumstances of your separation
maybe not being entirely accurate in how
you've described them to the Department
um perhaps the
um your work search efforts that are
required on your weekly claim perhaps
those are determined not to be accurate
so if it's determined that that
information
um should have been provided or was
provided in a way that was inaccurate
and was reasonable to know that you were
not providing the correct information
you will be at fault and you'll have to
repay that amount now we're not focusing
our fraud investigative resources on
those situations again we're focusing
those on unreported earnings so why some
why they're why they don't rise to the
level of fraud
you know the the real fraud that we're
worried about again is those unreported
earnings not necessarily tagging someone
for fraud for misrepresenting
um of some things on their work search
they'll find be found overpaid they'll
have to repay it in right now at a
cruise interest but we're not
considering those one weakers or those
short
periods of time for a fraud
investigation investigations at this
point so that's kind of the lay of the
land and and the context for how
individuals would find themselves to be
um
in the circumstance where they have been
paid benefits to which they are later
found to be ineligible and then the
situations in which they would have to
repay those and when when and when
interest does not accrue so I hope hope
that was helpful
um in terms of numbers
I'm looking at calendar year 2022
there were about
2400 claimants that were found overpaid
the total amount of overpaid benefits
was 2.7 million dollars that's out of uh
25 and a half million that was paid out
in regular State unemployment so a
little over 10 percent was found to be
improperly paid that's a little bit
higher than uh historically where New
Hampshire has been
we are one of the states that had
achieved the federal Benchmark of having
less than 10 percent of benefits paid be
determined to be improper leading up to
the pandemic my guess is that in uh you
know the first quarter here in 2023
that's probably back where we are I
don't have those numbers but we usually
hover in that eight to nine percent
range so that 10 10 is a little bit
higher than historical Norms
um of that 2.7 million that was found to
be overpaid about 45 of that are 1.2
million was in situations where the
individual was at fault in creating the
overpayment so those are the situations
that we what would be impacted here with
Senate bill 42. so again that was about
45 of those overpayments from 2022 about
1.2 million dollars was the amount that
individuals would have to repay and that
which would accrue interest if they
didn't repay that amount within 60 days
right thank you and before I go to you I
do have a question about
so the difference between at fault fraud
and if I read the language proposed in
this bill is there some kind of gray
area in there and what I'm getting at is
might we see kind of a
unintended shift in enforcement or
investigation because of the way the the
penalties are restructured
um so the the language and the statute
with regard to fraud requires an in
order to be found to have engaged in
unemployment fraud you need to have
acted willfully or intentionally with
regard to the information you provided
or didn't provide and that conduct needs
to be targeted in order for you to have
been provided benefits that you were not
eligible
so those efforts again are really
focused on individuals that don't report
their their work or their earnings uh
that you know we receive
a cross match between uh wage records
new hires all of that gets cross-matched
and compared against our benefit files
and that's how we determine whom we're
going to talk with when you get a call
from a fraud investigator or not good
so those are the individuals that fraud
investig investigators are talking with
to determine what occurred so it's
intentional willful conduct that needs
to be found after a process where we
talk with that individual allow them the
opportunity to explain what happened and
it's only after that that they would be
found to be have committed fraud now the
non-fraud situations again were largely
out of the unreported earnings area and
now you're with a situation where the
person's either at fault or without
fault in order to be at fault it needs
to be determined that it's the
information you provided that was
inaccurate it was a something that you
should have known was reasonable to know
that was inaccurate or it was
information that you did not provide
that was material to your claim was
reasonable to know that should have been
provided so those are those are
determinations that are made by
adjudicators in the department that are
trained on the unemployment statute and
they make those determinations based on
the fact find process that they have
with the individual and with the
employer before they issue those
determinations all right thank you
representative Schultz thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking our questions
um
what you shared answered some of my
questions but I the the implication from
the bill is that
um there are people that are continued
to be I don't know what the term is
build for overpayment the non-fraud
cases
um
for years possibly and I'm curious to
know how many people
from
2018 or how far back do you go to
continue to charge for that and
um
do you have a sense of how many cases
are still pending in that in that
category
um I I don't know that off the top of my
head but I can get that for you
representative and yes there there are
individuals that are still carrying
um overpayment debt dating back prior to
the pandemic uh for which
um some of them continue to make efforts
to repay perhaps they're in a a payment
agreement with the Department
um and while the debt continues the
interest continues to accrue but again
those are individuals that were at fault
in the in the creation of the of the
overpayment they do have an opportunity
at any point
um if they feel their circumstances
warranted or they can do it at the end
of paying off the principal of their
debt they can request a compromise from
the Department which is requesting that
the the balance of the debt be forgiven
because of their their circumstances and
the the standard that the department
applies is what is considered to be in
the best interest of the state so we
regularly make individuals aware of that
that was not the case
um probably 10 years ago that was kind
of a secret process that so secret yes
it was in statute but not very wasn't
communicated well to individuals we
changed that so now in the
determinations that individuals get
they're told right on that determination
of their opportunity to request a
compromise but yes there are individuals
that are are continuing to carry debt
some of it non-fraud that they're either
ignoring or maybe they're in an active
payment agreement but we can get you
those numbers
okay now now fraud overpayments are we
have the tools that we have to collect
those are quite aggressive we don't have
those same mechanisms for non-fraud
overpayments but fraud overpayments we
can offset your federal income tax
refunds we can Levy your bank account we
can record a real estate lien we can
garnish your wages so we have some
aggressive
mechanisms to encourage repayment of
fraudulent overpayments we do not have
those tools nor are we asking for them
for non-fraud overpayments okay that's
helpful to know and I you know
I also think it's important to keep
emphasizing this bill isn't for the
fraud cases this is for the non-brun
um and I would love to have a longer
discussion at another point about the
without fault cases where I imagine
um your department your commission your
department knows that people have
not done anything wrong there's just a
change in a determination or something
and they should be automatically not
included in that category I would hope
but how far back do you have this do you
have a number that you traditionally
continue to bill for
10 years five years and it would be
helpful to know as we make a decision
about this bill how much more than the
2022 number how much are we talking
about in interest I think it would be
helpful to know and how far back do you
continue to Bill
um so statute of limitations on the
types of overpayments so for non-fraud
situation the department is two years
um has two years from the impacted weeks
to issue a determination finding you
overpaid
sorry about that
um so two years for for finding someone
overpaid in a non-fraud situation for
fraud we have six years
then upon the determination meeting that
statute of limitations there for a
non-fraud situation we then have six
years in order to seek further
enforcement of that through filing a
writ in circuit court and seeking to
enforce that through a court order
that is not something regularly done
with non-fraud but it is something that
is done with fraud so those are some of
the statute of limitations that we have
in order to to comply with we also have
to obviously deal with bankruptcy orders
other things of that nature but to get
at your earlier Point representative if
it is a situation where you were put in
the wrong program
or just paid benefits maybe we screwed
up and we assigned wages to your base
period that were not yours
and you're you receive benefits and that
we later catch our error you will not
have to repay those benefits okay you
are without fault in doing that the
department screwed up we say it not
using those words but the department
made an error you are not found overpaid
you're not found to have to repay those
and it's not a situation that we're
dealing with here it's only those that
you provided us information that we
don't feel Rises to the level of of
needing to pursue a fraud investigation
but it's information that it was
reasonable to know was inaccurate either
about your separation or your work
search and then you're found to be
overpaid in those situations the
individual has to repay that and right
now a cruise interest after they exhaust
their appeals and after the 60 days from
when the determination goes final
next question uh representative Granger
uh thank you so I have a handful of
questions if you don't mind
um so the first one that might be
answered the other ones do you happen to
know where in 282a it gives the
department authority to charge interest
uh yeah it's throughout 282a I don't
have the site off the top of my head but
I'll get you that section
um
Marie Helene ballinson might have that
so 282a section 165 is what I'm being
told I don't think well I read once it's
not in 165 I don't think
okay okay um I'll just ask the next is
it okay to follow up
um but we have we have statutory
Authority and an obligation to charge
interest on on overpaid on
fraud and non-fraud claimant fault
overpayments as well as unpaid
unemployment taxes so it's a it's the
same consistent one percent in both
situations okay
uh so 141 and then that's in our the tax
section of our statute and then there's
a provision in the overpayment or
benefits section of the statute that
references back to saying we have the
authority described in 141.
perfect I believe is how it's structured
okay
um for a follow-up uh
two questions how is the interest rate
set and how much Liberty does the
commissioner have in with regard to how
much interest is charged is that set in
statute or is that yeah so statutes set
at one percent per month there's no
discretion
um in terms of
um
um charging um more or less interest
that's one percent per month per statute
so no discretion on the part of the
department the only discretion that the
department does have is someone who
comes in and and files a request for
compromise as I talked about before that
standard that set by Statute and there
are administrative rules on that where
it's a best interest of the state
standard and so someone could come in
and explain why their their
circumstances warrant forgiveness of a
debt it doesn't allow us to change the
interest that they're that they're
they're being charged if it's applicable
to their debt but they can get
forgiveness of the debt
okay thank you that's all I have
representative Valvoline
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Deputy Commissioner for being here with
us today
um the I just want to reference to the
2.7 million dollars from last year uh
1.2 is in recovery 1.5 is that charge to
the
fund for that loss correct those are uh
State unemployment benefit payments uh
that would have come out of the trust
fund and when they
um when they are repaid those payments
the principal portion of it goes back
into the trust fund
hello
um so the other part that is not
collected whether it be administratively
or Not by egregious
um is that cost passed on to the
business owners if the in terms of the
impact on their tax rate so I guess
there there are two answers to this
question on the tax rate side no there's
there's not an impact so if if the
individual is determined to be at fault
that does not is not a charge against
your experience that then influences
your tax rate
however
there are also reductions to your tax
rate that are triggered by the balance
of the trust fund right so all of our
solvency controls for New Hampshire's
trust fund are contained within statute
and are based on the balance in the
trust fund so perhaps if the trust fund
did not meet one of those Balance
thresholds and it was really close call
that could have an impact where
Employers in general not a particular
employer but Employers in general would
not receive that fund balance reduction
as it's referenced in statute
follow up thank you and for the last one
all the administrative costs to recover
all these funds is that charge to the
fund or is that charge to the
administrative portion it's charged to
the administrative portion but it's paid
for by employers so
um we we receive uh about 51 percent of
our budget is in the form of different
federal grants for the unemployment
program re-employment Services labor
market information and then the balance
of that is paid for out of the
administrative fund that is paid for
quarterly by employers they have a
portion of their their tax payment that
gets diverted from the trust fund to
support the administration of the
program and so the administrative costs
in pursuing collection are absorbed by
those administrative payments thank you
thank you Mr chairman other questions
ah representative Cahill
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
wavers I believe I just heard you say
that the uh the you didn't mention where
the interest goes if you when they are
paid as the interest go uh towards or
the uh fund or elsewhere uh the the
interest gets deposited in the
administrative fund
so in in 20 I think it was in the fiscal
note but let me just make sure it's
correct
so fiscal year 22 not calendar but
fiscal year 22 uh the department
collected just over ninety one thousand
dollars in interest from non-fraud
overpaid benefits and that went into the
administrative fund which helps my
friend Mr avalani and others who would
contribute to that fund correct
very good and to be clear uh this this
this law that we passed this bill this
will only reduce the burden on people
who did not make an intentional effort
but had an honest mistake something
happened and uh they uh they still repay
the the amounts they received just not
the interest
correct so this bill so it individuals
that are that are with fault in creating
the overpaid benefits
um they would still have an overpayment
they'd still have to repay that
principal amount but if the bill were to
pass there wouldn't be interest accruing
on that debt
any further questions
I don't see any this was the last card
representative Broody if you could pass
the blue sheet up for this bill
um thank you and online right now we
have signed in for support 31 names 5 in
opposition
okay here it comes
um
and signed in on the blue sheet in
addition to Deputy Commissioner lavers
uh we also have the other
Don McKinney who testified
so with that I'll close the public
hearing for SB 42 and open the next one
sb193 Senator Prentice is the prime
sponsor and will introduce the bill
good morning and a thank you chair
seaworth or vice chair c worth I was ex
I have to say I was expecting chair
infantine who I went to college with we
graduated in 1986 with St Michael's
College I'm I always uh I'm not sure
that he remembers that but I certainly
do it was a while ago but you'll be
watching the video so if he doesn't
representative infantine so good morning
um
members of House labor industrial and
rehabilitative services committee for
the record my name is suprentice I'm the
state senator from District Five
covering 15 communities a large part of
Grafton County a few towns in Sullivan
County and one in Merrimack County the
beautiful town of New London New
Hampshire I do hail from West Lebanon
New Hampshire so I'm here today to
introduce Senate Bill 193 this is a
bipartisan effort it will amend RSA 373
A3 the obligation to bargain in good
faith the purpose of this amendment is
to provide a tool by which a bargaining
unit and a public employer will initiate
a timeline to begin and to work within
once a request has been made to bargain
and I trust you already know that
collective bargaining is a process
through which the union and the employer
exchange proposals share ideas mutually
solve problems and reach a written
agreement
most times bargaining occurs when an
existing contract is going to expire in
order to ensure timely negotiations and
a settlement of the issues time is of
the essence if a request to enter into
bargaining occurs and is not responded
to again in a timely manner the process
can be unnecessarily prolonged with this
prolongment comes unintended
consequences you have a budget that's
waiting to be informed as a result of
this you have
benefits that need to be implemented
adjusting of pay adjusting of tax rates
there are just a number of consequences
that can happen down the line the longer
that this goes on so what 193 does is it
makes a request to enter in two
negotiations within 10 days of the
request or by mutual agreement to extend
that 10-day window so if a request is
made and it can't be responded to right
away then the employer would come back
and say I can't do this Within These 10
days can we mutually agree on a timeline
this is a Communications tool again it
sets X it sets expectations and it opens
what is a crucial line of Communications
in this process so with that I thank you
for your time and consideration
I will make my best attempt to answer
any questions you have I have some folks
that are with me and I do need to get
back to the Senate because we are in
session and I have a particular floor
speech that I'd like to make but I do
appreciate your time thank you
are there any questions for the senator
we don't want to hold you up so thank
you very much for your testimony and
good luck in the center thank you very
much thank you for all the work you do
thank you
um the next card that I have is Nicole
argraves representing nhnea
she will speak in support of the bill
and I see another card do you you want
to testify together so also uh Brian
Hawkings of the Nea New Hampshire has
turned in a card in support of the bill
with written testimony yes thank you Mr
chairman we thought we'd save you a few
minutes and testify together uh for the
record Brian Hawkins representing uh Nea
New Hampshire we represent uh hundreds
of bargaining units across the state and
support them in their collective
bargaining negotiations I want to thank
Senator Apprentice for uh bringing this
bill forward as she alliterated this as
a pro collective bargaining process bill
that that really we feel then it truly
benefits both sides and we appreciate
the bipartisan support that are received
in the Senate
um I hope that will be the case here as
well
um the Genesis of this borrows from a an
existing long time existing law in the
state of Maine and so to that end today
we have with us Nicole R Graves who is
one of our unicer of directors who
assists our locals and collective
bargaining negotiations and has done so
in both the state of New Hampshire and
in the state of Maine with some
experience under there so with that I'll
turn it over to her
good morning
um my name is Brian said it's Nicole a
Graves I'm here to speak to you today in
support of Senate bill 193. I've been an
active Union member involved in Union
work for over 25 years this experience
has included 15 years serving as a staff
member with several unions which
includes the Maine state employees
Association
the main Education Association and the
New Hampshire Education Association
I currently serve as the uniserv
director for the Seacoast region in New
Hampshire with the New Hampshire
Education Association I represent both
teaching and support staff in the
schools in the Seacoast region over the
course of my tenure as a staff member
collective bargaining for employees has
been a core function of the work I do on
behalf of members of unions while
negotiations can be tens of times on
both parties both parties do tend to
work together very hard to be
professional and Define common ground as
efficiently as possible
in order to make this happen the parties
have to be open flexible and timely with
scheduling negotiations
both parties must recognize the existing
timeline to get a new contract in place
and work collaboratively to schedule
meetings however there are occasions one
has been incredibly challenging for
associations to bring board teams to the
table to negotiate in a timely fashion
when this happens it undermines the
mutual obligations of the parties and
frustrates the entire bargaining process
in Maine this was recognized and a
process was codified into law to provide
a tool to the parties to overcome any
intentional or unintentional delays of
the collecting collective bargaining
process after the initial demand to
bargain had been issued
under Public Employee labor law
relations 26 MRSA section 965 1B
either party in the process is able to
issue a 10-day demand to bargain upon
the other party
once the demand has been issued within
10 days
after receipt of the written notice from
the other party the party receiving the
notice must meet with the party issuing
the notice for the purpose of bargaining
and as you heard a little bit earlier
Extensions by mutual agreement can be
granted this tool ensures the parties
continue to negotiate in good faith
during negotiations it is important to
note that Maine does not have the strict
timelines that we have here to ratify a
contract in New Hampshire
yet they still saw the wisdom in
providing this additional tool to the
parties in order to maintain uh the
obligations of both the top parties to
be efficient with the timeline
they saw the value in preventing
existing contracts from becoming expired
before new contract to be put in place
they also saw the value in preventing
further deliberations between the
parties regarding retroactivity of wages
and benefits related to the expiration
of a contract it was recognized that
these scenarios cause unrest with the
workforce and that it strains Labor
Management relations main lawmakers saw
the wisdom in preventing this and
reinforcing the mutual obligations to
meet at reasonable times by providing
this tool
I was with the Maine Education
Association for a little over four years
I had this tool available to me and I
only had to use it roughly three times
related to refusals to me in a timely
fashion
this was when weeks had gone by and
every day the association offered was
rejected and no dates were provided to
us in the alternative when contracts are
approaching exploration and labor was
becoming increasingly distressed and we
had failed yet to reach an agreement in
those instances this tool was invaluable
and allowed us to request the team to to
meet with us to continue negotiations
without this tool the contracts in those
places would have expired while we were
still waiting for the other party to
agree to dates to meet using this tool
three times Over a four-year period
isn't what I would call excessive
or frequent by any means but it was
available when we truly needed it to
make the difference for the workers in
those Public Schools
in New Hampshire as you know we have a
multi-layered process to pass contracts
once agreements have been reached they
must be ratified by the Association by
the district and then by the town
so that so time must be built in
planning well in advance of negotiations
actually happening
further we don't have true Evergreens in
New Hampshire so wages freeze if we
expire without any guarantee of
retroactivity and we have strict
timelines for our sb2 school districts
to be ready for the last stage of
ratification with the community so
pressure is mounting long before even
the initial demand is issued from the
association
our guidelines say that sb2 school
districts we must issue our initial
demand at least 120 days before the
contracts expire and we also need to
keep an eye on the second week of
November to know roughly by November
14th if we're going to be able to reach
a final contract or if we're going to be
an impasse and need to look at advanced
process
if we aren't close enough to settling a
contract by the second week of November
and we don't call impasse we simply
won't have enough time for mediation and
or to reconvene to finalize a contract
this means employees will be at status
quo and no new contract will be issued
no wage increases will be provided and
no potential will be provided for
improvement in any benefits
being mindful of this our demands to
bargain for contracts due to be
negotiated are issued at least in August
and we have roughly three and a half
months to get and get contracts in place
where we can say confidently whether we
will or will not have a contract ready
to be ratified by the parties
every day we wait to start the
bargaining process as a day lost in that
window and we have no time to waste
budgets as you know in late November and
early December
in Seacoast I'm responsible for
assisting teacher and support staff
locals to negotiate their collective
bargaining agreements over the last four
years I've negotiated anywhere between 7
and 16 collective bargaining agreements
each negotiation cycle
during the current negotiation cycle I
had 11 contracts to negotiate and
getting a good place by November I can
tell you with no reservation that
despite issuing demands to bargain in
August every year or earlier it is
extremely rare that any school board is
ready and or willing to reconvene or to
convene with us in August or over the
summer period despite requests to meet
in the summer or even in August and the
earliest dates we normally get to
convene with the school boards are in
mid-september which becomes increasingly
differently when difficult when schools
are also starting up in September
um I've even had some school boards come
back with dates that they're available
to begin negotiations in October
I've had Two school boards in my region
start starting negotiations in late
October both also had delays during the
process beyond the late start in October
this left me with less than a month
before I had to make a decision on
whether or not we were at impasse in
both of these scenarios we had to go to
mediation and the parties had to pay for
an advance process that likely would not
have been needed if we had started
earlier
we were able to successfully reach an
agreement in one of those contracts just
in time but we did not for the other
contract and those support staff went an
entire year without any wages or
benefits increase this was unnecessary
speaking from experience I can tell you
that most of the time late starts and
delays in the bargaining process has to
do with the schedules of specific
individuals to serve on the school board
and or attorney's board
if they are using one it is the ability
to negotiate at reasonable times that
causes the issue sometimes that happens
with the associations team as well
although we work fairly diligently to
elect team members who know they have to
be flexible with their schedule
when we are unsuccessful in negotiating
a time in a timely fashion we simply
won't have a contract ready
wages and benefits won't be addressed
when seasoned employees become Frozen
onstep due to an expired contract often
that means new hires are being brought
into the district at a step that is
close if not on or above the level of
seasoned employees your existing
employees will feel undervalued Labor
Management relations worsen and we see
the Exodus of seasoned employees
professionals from the school district's
increase we are not at a time and place
right now with education that we can
afford to have seasoned employees leave
the district from the teacher or
paraprofessional ranks and we are not
having floods of new employees come in
and education through the teacher or
paraprofessional ranks and we are
experiencing significant staff shortages
in both the teacher and paraprofessional
groups I have anywhere in the upwards
bounds in many of my Region
20 vacancies and support staff groups
and significant vacancies in the teacher
groups if we don't have these contracts
ready to pass we will see
significantly larger vacancies and our
ability to support the children in the
communities that go to these Public
Schools is going to become increasingly
problematic for the general population
of children and for the special
education population who have IEP
demands that have to be meeting a legal
threshold
um we have an obligation as parties to
meet at a reasonable time frame and to
support Public Schools public education
teachers and our support staff Senate
Bill 193 established a requirement for
the parties to meet within 10 days once
the request has been issued we believe
this bill provides a vital tool for the
parties to be able to come together and
to continue to negotiate in good faith
it does not compel either party to agree
to anything but it does bring them to
the table to continue to negotiate as
they are obligated to as I experience in
Maine I suspect this tool will be
available as a last resort and will not
be used frequently however having it
available will continue to motivate the
parties to engage in a timely fashion
and it will preserve the positive Labor
Management relations between the parties
and make a significant difference for
all public employees when delays become
an issue in the process and I do believe
it'll help continue to keep the
contracts in a healthy place to preserve
and protect the staff we have and bring
more quality employees to the public
education field thank you thank you for
your testimony and that testimony you
have written copies thank you if you
could pass those out when you're done I
would appreciate it
um I do have a question you mentioned at
least one specific case and I assume
that problems motivated uh the language
of this bill
was there any case of let's say a
deliberate delay that was brought to the
pelrb
and if so what happened we had one case
with a deliberate delay was brought to
the plrb but there were other issues
that was brought in that case as well
and so
um the delivery delay was not something
that was at the Forefront of the
argument and it wasn't specifically
addressed by the plrb rather the other
issues that were brought were
um were addressed in the final order all
right thank you
other questions representative McKenzie
thank you
everybody knows when the contract ends
correct correct and everybody knows what
the date's going to be correct and you
know that years ahead of time in some
cases yeah thank you
other questions representative Granger
uh thank you
um
so why would anyone delay a timely
meeting uh what's what's the what's
generally the purpose of uh delaying um
so for instance I believe you said that
it benefits both sides what I'm trying
to get at is uh why why do we need to
have a law for it if it's in both sides
interest
um what we see frequently happen and
sometimes it's untouched a lot of times
it's unintentional but what we see
frequently happen is when when both
sides select their teams I think and
frequently we see it with the board
teams there isn't a lot of vetting about
availability for schedules and sometimes
when that team is formed from the board
side one or more members of the team
have restrictions on their availability
and so
um we try very hard when we form the
association teams to let people know
that if they they become part of the
team they have to be extremely flexible
because we need to move this contract as
quickly as possible and they're
motivated because these are also their
wages and benefits and working
conditions and not to say that the board
doesn't take the negotiation seriously
because I believe they do but I think
when these individuals come to the table
the dates that come across to them
simply and a lot of times don't work in
their personal lives so often they're
having to say I can't do that day I
can't do that day I can't do that day so
I think this will help give the parties
um more focus when they're selecting a
team to make it clear that that we need
to be able to get to the table in a
timely fashion and if this if this
request is issued we have two weeks to
get there and you need to make your
schedule work or we may have to go to
the table without you or select an
alternative I think it's going to force
the parties to think more clearly about
who they have at the table and
Alternatives if people have conflicts
follow up so uh if you're if you're a
member of a school board
um and you want to pursue other options
rather than working with the Union uh
would this sort of prohibit that because
you're still forced to engage in
negotiations with the Union
um I'm not sure I understand your
question well if you're in a school
board and you don't want to continue
pursuing negotiations with the Union if
the town decides that they want to go in
another route wouldn't this sort of
prevent that
I think it would I think it would force
you to have to come to the table in two
weeks
um your Chief negotiator would have to
reach out to the association make
arrangements to come to the table you
have to negotiate in good faith and this
gets you there it doesn't compel you to
agree to anything so at the end of the
day you may still reach a place where
you don't have a contract but it won't
because it won't be because you didn't
convene it'll be because you couldn't
mutually agree on terms this won't Force
the parties to reach agreement it forces
the parties to come to the table and
continue to have those constructive
discussions
thank you
other questions
and I'll come back to you if if anyone
else has a first question
I uh representative
thank you for taking my question thank
you Mr chair uh you just mentioned two
weeks would you be uh uh okay with 10
working days
yeah I mean it's a 10-day demand so
essentially the schools only really meet
during work days so it would be 10
working days I say two weeks because we
don't generally meet on weekends but I
have in my in the past we've made
exceptions in many weekends but that's
not the norm with education you're
correct thank you
representative McKenzie thank you
there's nothing in the law that prevents
you six months out four months out three
months out from meeting with the with
the employer's team and coming up with
schedules at that point knowing full
well that the contrast is going to
expire correct there's nothing in fact
when we meet at the ground Rules meeting
we set a schedule in advance but
sometimes that schedule is just not kept
with because people determine they have
conflicts and that's often what causes
the issue thank you
any further questions
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you thank you very much I have one
final card on this bill
um
Alan RAF representing the New Hampshire
AFL-CIO
in support of the bill with written
testimony
foreign
thank you Mr chairman honorable
committee members my name is Alan RAF
and on behalf of the New Hampshire
AFL-CIO and our over 35 000 members I
come for you to ask you to vote to pass
on Senate Bill 193 which is a bipartisan
effort sponsored by legislators in both
chambers of both parties my brothers
sisters from the Nea just did a lot of
what I was going to do so in the
interest of time I will scoot down to
the middle of this testimony and say
um so in the process uh the negotiation
process obviously timeliness is
extremely important when an existing
contract is set to expire it serves the
interest the employer the employees and
the organization to negotiate and or to
initiate the negotiations and conclude
them before a contract expires in the
event that the contract expires without
a new one agreed to it's not only the
workers seeking the agreement that
suffer but the Employers in the
organization as well this can create
tension between the workers and the
management which is bad and has
consequences of its own but even more
crucially in some cases this could mean
a delay in services that are vital to
the functioning of a state municipality
a branch of either of those so in
conclusion this bill strengthens the
entire process of bargaining providing
all parties with the competence trust
and reasonable expectations regarding
the negotiation process and the contract
at hand and it's for these reasons that
we urge you to vote ought to pass on
this so thank you guys I take any
questions that you have thank you very
much for your testimony are there
questions
I don't see any so thank you again Mr
chairman that was the final pink card I
had if there are no others
representative baruti if you could get
the blue sheet for this bill
and while that's being passed up the
online
sign in had 45 signing in in support and
six in opposition
thank you representative
and
um in addition to
I think testimony
uh there was there was one additional
person signed in in support in person
um I will now close the hearing
for SB 193 and we're already scheduled
to start the next one I am a co-sponsor
on this next bill so I am going to step
down and representative avalani will uh
chair this hearing
thank you Mr chairman uh we have
Jennifer Gallagher in for uh Senator
Susie to introduce house bill 269.
so sorry uh Jennifer Gallagher Senator
soucy's assistant she is in session so
with your Indulgence I'm going to
introduce Senate bill 269.
this bill is the result of an agreement
between the Department of Labor and the
restaurant and Lodging Association
providing clarifying language
this bill would clarify the
responsibilities of those who are
involved in tip pooling and its
Administration
an employer can establish and administer
a policy suggest a customary and usual
tip and resolve disputes
additionally it would resolve an issue
where businesses are paying taxes on
service charges despite tips or
gratuities being the property of an
employee
the department and the industry should
be here to answer any questions you may
have
thank you
thank you for your introduction any
questions for Miss Gallagher
thank you thank you
next up is Mr Summers from the
restaurant and Lodging Association
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Mike Summers I'm the president CEO of
the New Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association we worked with the uh here
in support of Senate Bill 269. uh we're
here in support of the bill
um
really this came around this is really
in our mind is two technical Corrections
and I'll walk you through the two
Corrections and I'll let Deputy
Commissioner Ogden kind of clarify
because he's the he's the detail
specialist but really there's two things
we're trying to accomplish here the
first is under current statute there is
a definition of a tip which includes the
term service charge which creates a
little bit of a conflict for our
industry because under IRS rules uh a
service charge is automatically income
of the business and therefore taxable
under IRS tax rules but under state law
under in the um in the definition of a
tip or gratuity uh it is considered a
typical gratuity and therefore
automatically owned by the employee
receiving the tip or the gratuity so now
you have this weird situation where a
business is being taxed on income that
it never receives and actually belongs
to the employee so that really is a
technical correction it's one that we've
had discussions with Department of Labor
and I think they agree with us on on
this slight change
the other piece is around tip pulling
and tip sharing language
and we've had some businesses that have
kind of run into some quirky problems
where uh you know in the air their
attempt to essentially assist their
employees with their tip sharing or tip
pooling Arrangement and the document
documentation thereof uh it has come to
a situation where the department uh has
ruled that you know they have
said or done something inadvertently and
because of the way this language is
currently in statute which says that it
has to be the request of the employee
you know the the employer is essentially
uh having a conversation saying you know
hey what are we doing with this how is
this going to be handled and at that
point technically they're in violation
of the statute so the point here is to
really just remove that piece of it
allow open discourse between the two it
does not change the current policy where
the tips are owned by the employee that
their participation in a tip pulling a
tip sharing Arrangement is still
voluntary without coercion so it doesn't
really change that it just changes this
uh one little piece in the statute which
has created a lot of friction between
businesses and the department and
statutes so I think that's kind of the
Crux of it all and I'm happy to try to
answer any questions
anywhere uh representative Cahill
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Summers for taking my question I'm I'm
completely in agreement to understand
about the service chart I'm just going
to change that to gratuity and I'm
assuming that on all the receipts that
the restaurants have it'll say gratuity
instead of service charge uh I'm a
little bit concerned about the tip
pooling tip sharing because I I did read
your uh I read the Senate testimony and
I believe you said that tip pooling is
rare
which sounds a little odd because I you
know we have go to a restaurant you see
the the server takes the the dollars
that used to be dollars and put it puts
it in the jar and they all get a piece
of that later uh that's different from I
guess how it works with the credit cards
and so you you would record all the uh
tips that are listed on the credit card
you know six dollars for this whatever
that is and then at the end of that
these are still shared among all this
all the way staff correct is that
correct
yes and no so let me clarify
yeah I know that's a bad spell
replacement I I just want to address you
correct I think directly but so that let
me clarify the difference between tip
pooling and tip sharing so tip pooling
is what you characterize where
everything goes into a jar the scenario
is where we see that most often would be
behind a bar you have three bartenders
the kind of all crossing over each other
helping customers they all have access
to the same register almost impossible
to determine who owns what part of the
tip so therefore they come to some
arrangement within their group of what
the tip pool will look like how it's
calculated who gets what the other
instance we see it most commonly is and
I guess a similar characterization to a
bar would be also a scenario like Dunkin
Donuts for example where you have
numerous people are working a register
people go back and forth there's no real
ownership of the tip necessarily and so
it'd be kind of a collective uh you know
group and they would decide how they
wanted to break it up amongst themselves
the other scenario where we see tip
pulling pretty common is usually in
function facilities so a function
facility because you know you have such
a large number of people waiting on such
a large number of people almost
impossible to determine how much of each
individual guest or participant towards
the gratuity would be uh attributable to
each individual employee if that makes
sense so then they have to come to some
sort of an agreement about how it's
going to be divvied up amongst everyone
who's participating
tip sharing is different in that in a
tip sharing arrangement in a restaurant
you would have a scenario where I have a
section I have five or six tables of my
five or six tables I am clearly the
direct owner of those tips I waited on
the table I collected the tips from the
table etc etc and in that scenario tip
share would be where they may tip out
some at the end of the night to the
bartender who did a nice job for them
making their service drinks or to the
food Runner that brought the food to the
table or whatever it might be the bus
boy they cleaned the table so that is
more of a tip share Arrangement the
credit card piece of it really doesn't
come into it because the ownership is
still clear depending on the scenario
you find yourself in if that makes sense
uh thank you I think it does uh it's
only that if if the restaurant isn't
really divided up into sections that
this person Waits on that table that
person Waits on that table and the
credit card the fee the tax the tips are
putting the credit cards which nobody
carries cash and that at the end of it
do are the tips not pooled in that
situation they go to that person and
that person correct so so you know if
you have a section and you have assigned
tables then that tip it may you know the
business May hold and pay you in your
paycheck at the next pay period or they
may have enough cash in the building to
give you tips when you leave that night
it kind of depends on you know what
credit cards it's created some problems
but ultimately the owner of those tips
in that situation is the employee the
the server that waited on that table
follow-up
thank you my other concern here is is
about what if you have somebody who
wants to work as a server but doesn't
really want to participate in the pool
then again we have a corrosion but
absolutely and there's no requirement
that they participate
how does that work in sorry how does
that work in the real world
well in the real world they would uh
just at the end of the shift and and
because at the end of the shift when you
cash out with the business right this is
where you if you have more cash than you
have tips then you would remit to the
business to cover the checks that you
collected on Etc this is where the
determination or the question would be
asked do you want to tip anyone out
tonight and so this is where businesses
have run into trouble because now there
are they're essentially asking that
question at the end of a shift and so
now a business could ultimately be said
to be participating in discussion that
needs to be inspired by the employee and
so again not requiring coercion or
participation the employee can simply
say I didn't do well tonight I'm not
participating in the tip share
interesting thank you very much welcome
any further questions for our Mr Summers
representative McKenzie thank you
so there are many restaurants that you
go into today where somebody Waits on
you takes the order somebody drops a
salad off different somebody drops the
meal off different uh somebody collects
a food at the end of the night different
so how does that work
I guess which part of that so when you
go to who gets a tip and it's a tip
shared with all of the people that
dropped the salad off and and did that
kind of thing during the course not
necessarily so so the scenario I didn't
think I'd be explaining restaurant
operations but here we go so ultimately
if a server has a section is assigned a
table the tip belongs to the server
at that point the server at the end of
the night may just decide that hey you
know this Susie did a great job busting
my tables all night I'm going to give
her a little something extra that's
essentially how it works so at the point
that this server is assigned those
tables any tips that are generated by
that table belong to that employee
one final one so you've just you said uh
something made a statement about at the
end of the night when they remit to the
employer
so what did you mean by that statement
because
there were some um practices within
where the where the uh uh wage staff
would be paying be paying for the booze
be paying for the liquor for instance at
the end of the night they may go up to
the bar and and uh and reconcile that
with the employee that's not what you're
talking about when you made that
statement I'm saying that at the end of
a shift you would cash out as an employ
as a as a server because during the
course of the night right so you're
running credit cards you keep those
credit card receipts you may receive
cash whatever it might be at the end of
the night you're just settling up you
have a uh you issue a
you know what I'm saying so you have a a
receipt a receipt that you give to the
the manager checking you out and shows
your gross sales what was food what was
beverage et cetera et cetera and at the
end of it there's essentially a
Reconciliation about I need this many
credit card slips from you I need this
much cash or I owe you this much cash
because in today's environment with
credit cards more often than not the
business owners them cash simply because
the credit card tips Etc are usually
much greater than any cash they may have
received
um so hopefully that answers your
question thank you yeah the employee at
no point is paying for any of this this
is just the reconciliation of the stuff
they've collected from customers over
the course of the night and they're
remitting it to the business
representative Schultz
um so in this the way it's written and
following up a little bit on his
question
what determines who
belongs in each category is that the sub
minimum wage worker or do they could
they earn the regular
minimum wage as a bus person I don't
know I think yeah I'm actually going to
defer some of the answer to your
question to uh Ruby Ogden but ultimately
if you are the way the statute's written
if you are a directly tipped employee
you are the server then you can be paid
a sub minimum wage if you are not a
directly tipped employee you have to be
paid at least minimum wage
so the busboy the food Runner the
hostess everyone has to make at least
minimum wage and then they may receive
some tips but it's not guaranteed but
they must be paid at least at minimum
wage
thank you again Mr Summers so again with
the with the uh the all the the bus boys
and Runners and the and everybody else
who's participating and likely to
receive a tip from the as George do you
look at that and say well do they get
routinely thirty dollars in tips every
month and now I don't have to pay the
minimum wage no because uh if they are
indirectly tipped AKA they may get may
get a tip from an employee a server Etc
it's required and I could uh Deputy
Ogden can certainly speak to that thank
you
any further questions for Mr Summers
representative love
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um well where are we here um
on line 14 provided that the employer
does not require our course employees to
participate in tip pool and a tip
sharing Arrangement
um I uh I I go to a restaurant where it
certainly seems like all the tips
including credit card tips are put into
a jar or you know that they're written
down and at the end of the night it
seems like everybody
um you know the the waitress the bus you
know the the bartenders all all uh take
from that pool uh
this is saying that the the employer
could not say upon hiring this is the
way we do it
uh if you agree to it you can work here
if you don't I can't make separate
arrangements for you uh no I I would not
recommend any business to that the
Department of Labor would frown
seriously upon that and I would
certainly uh urge Deputy Ogden to uh
comment on that but ultimately
um you know the perception may be that
everything gets pulled but that's not
really the actuality or how it actually
works in the industry there are
Exceptions there are some that operate
that way because they're um they don't
really have a signed section so
everybody's in charge of everything at
all times and in those situations it
does there may be a scenario like that
but those are kind of the uh exception
rather than the rule uh more often if
you have a sit-down restaurant where
somebody takes your order and brings you
drinks and food Etc most of the time and
I would say 99 of the time maybe at
least
um in almost all those situations that
tip would belong to that server employee
that has an assigned section and they
may or may not share depending on you
know how their night goes and that kind
of thing
okay thank you
any further questions for Mr Summers
I just have one
on the service charge yes sir
um typically that is a for like a party
of eight or ten that's automatically
um given an adjustment or somebody that
requests a service charge for separate
tickets for a party of 10.
um with that Taken Out is it employers
no longer allowed to ask for service
charges
so so you're looking at it purely
through the lens of a restaurant a table
service restaurant
this also applies to the broader
function facility right and so in some
scenarios we have seen
um let me ask you answer your question
first so you could still use the term
service charge and you could still give
all of it to the employee that's
entirely up to you we're not we're just
not making it that it is required that
that would be the case and what most
restaurants will do and I think you
would agree with this
um they would put it in as a tip or a
gratuity
um so that the customer knows that
that's what it is but again you could
certainly have a scenario where you use
a service charge but again we've
cautioned a lot of restaurants against
using service charge because the IRS
then considers it uh income of the
business and therefore taxable so what
we've said to folks is come up with
another way to do it call it
administrative fee whatever you want to
call it so that you know it's still
required to be paid by the uh by the
customer and then you share that with
your employees or however you want to do
it but ultimately the term service
charge is what became problematic when
the IRS changed their determination
number of years ago
thank you for that clarification
um and on the documenting agreed upon
practice in section two yes
um if you have a documented
a practice with a number of wages with a
number of employees that are operating
in your facility and you have one
employee in relations to representative
Love's question a new employee coming in
that doesn't want to go with that uh how
does that work if there's already a
documented agreement in place that the
new employee is not going to follow that
is that a violation if we don't hire
them or is that a violation if they
don't participate because there is an
already an agreed upon practice for the
employee employer so the agreed upon
practice is not agreed upon because the
employer dictated what the practice will
be the agreed upon practice is what the
employees themselves have said okay this
is how we want to handle it within our
business this is what we're all
comfortable with this is what we want to
do
with the caveat that they can still jump
in and out of this agreement at any time
by shift if they would like
um part of where the and again I think
the department has also said look we we
agree with that that you could if you
have a new employee coming in you can
say this is how it's currently handed
within the business handled within the
business I think the department the
employee can still say that they don't
want to participate in that I think
where the department would have a
problem is if you did not hire them
simply because they did not want to
participate because now you get into
that coercive environment so I think
that we would not encourage any business
to make hiring practices based upon what
the employee wants to do
participating in the pool or not because
the employee
at any time has has the uh the option to
participate or not participate
thank you any further questions for Mr
Summers
thank you thank you
Mr Rady
from Shaheen Finney
good morning welcome
I'll be brief
um I'm a management side attorney for
the record my name is James Reedy it's
she and Finney and
um I'm in support of this bipartisan
Bill I'm a management side lawyer
meaning I represent employers of all
shapes and sizes but I represent a
number of businesses in the hospitality
industry and I have dealt with this
language this current language several
times uh and it's already been been
discussed by uh or outlined by Mr
Summers and by the sponsor but it's
effectively awkward language the
employer can
administer a policy the employer can
have a policy administer the policy and
deal with disputes and even assist with
the distribution or apportionment
directed by the employees but I can't
discuss it in the first instance
and this is hamstrung the Department of
Labor in a few cases a few recent cases
I've had where they say it has to be at
the request of the employee
and I don't know how many of you have
ever worked in the industry but um
imagine a server coming into a
restaurant for the first time or coming
into the busy summer season a lot of
younger workers coming in and they
wouldn't know enough about a tip pool or
a tip share
and what that means so unless they utter
the magic words then the employer could
not discuss it with them again the discu
the employer can have a policy again
proposed by the employees at some point
administer it and deal with disputes and
they can talk also talk about customary
unusual amounts that could be shared
but they can't mention in the first
instance so this would take away that
language but it preserves the intent of
the statute which it has to be voluntary
and to a question earlier the uh the
server can withdraw on a daily basis I
opt out today the census was low I
didn't feel like I got assistance from
others I choose not to it's a
self-governing system effectively among
the similarly situated employees
and this would change it and preserve
the intent of the statute
thank you any questions for Mr Reedy
representative McKenzie
thank you for appearing appreciate it
um
I've I've worked with this issue for a
long time from my days in the AFL-CIO
um and one of the things that's always
I'm always interested in is the issue of
uh not coercing employees
um and I understand workplaces have been
in a lot of them negotiated a lot of
contracts over the course of the years
in this case you have a bunch of
employees in a restaurant and you you
are giving them the opportunity to to
exercise their own uh decision about
what they think is best for them
and there is no coercion that goes on
and yet there's nothing in this that
that says
um that there's when the employer
violates that
there's no there's no fine unless there
may be something that the commissioner
will bring forward
so when you look at that Dynamic do you
have any comments about that Dynamic
you've got the owner and you've got an
employee you've got somebody that wants
to participate somebody doesn't do you
have any comments about that I do be and
thank you for your question I I've had
that case a number of times and so the
statute provides that the the employer
Can it can help to mediate or resolve
disputes this happens all the time when
someone is tipping out pretty regularly
sharing the tips with similarly situated
employees I'm sorry pooling with
similarly situated employees or sharing
with non-tipped employees and then
someone who's not tipping out for
whatever reason on any particular day or
just in perpetuity and that generally
speaking is settled between the staff
and like I said it's a self-governing
system because if you're sharing tips
with an expediter a busser a Hostess and
so on they're likely to get better uh
better service from those individuals
and all all boats rise with the tide but
to your question with regard to can and
the employer coerce and pressure and say
well this is our policy and if you don't
cooperate things are likely to go bad
well that would likely be a violation of
the statute and that's when the
Department of Labor would get involved
and when does that typically happen a
disgruntled employee says I was forced
or coerced or was in a system whereby I
was pressured to tip and I didn't want
to and then they file a complaint with
the Department of Labor
just for the final question oh
so the idea that the that the employer
is the one that mediates the dispute
do you see that as as problematic in any
way in that that's not exactly a neutral
that's negotiating in the end is those
are reasons why many times they end up
with the DOL
uh thanks for and I think that's a good
question it's a practical question I
think the bottom line is what's the
what's the purpose of uh running
whatever the business is let's say it's
a restaurant it's to provide that prompt
service that quality service to its
customers and it doesn't do well if its
employees are not getting along so it
wants to preserve the piece if at all
possible
um my experience with customers is with
employers is they try to be right down
the middle in that regard which is look
I don't care how you divide it you can
tip out whatever percentage you want to
and that's the other thing as long as
you're above the the minimum wage sub
minimum wage plus tips above the minimum
wage you can do whatever you want or not
and some are more generous than not just
this most people have been tipping over
the last couple of years especially but
um the the interest of the employer in
that regard is not the tip system but
instead maintain the peace and the
quality of service the restaurant
any further questions
thank you Mr thank you
uh we have Deputy Commissioner Ogden
thank you everybody Ogden New Hampshire
Department of Labor I'm happy to take
any questions but I'd start by answering
some of the questions that have already
come up specifically representative love
your uh question relative to essentially
employees at time of interview being
told this is how we do it and that's uh
basically needed for someone to get a
job the department would take that as
coercive specifically we would look at
such a scenario and imagine the impact
that that would have on the existing
staff so if again you look at a system
where an employer says this is how we do
it if you want to work here this is how
it's done we would view that as coercive
and representative McKenzie in terms of
your question or comments relative to
coercion it unfortunately does come up
the statute 279 one actually gives a
definition of coercion in this context
and it says it's an instance in which an
adverse employment action is taken
against an employee relative to their
decision to tip or not tip or anything
of that nature in terms of what the the
liability or issues related to such
complaints uh the department when we
deal with those findings we essentially
there's a wage adjustment where if we
come in and we see that there has been
coercion we would say that all of the
monies that have been funneled through
that share or pool and I would Echo Mr
Summer's comments that most typically
we're seeing shares as opposed to pools
but we would say that any money is being
funneled through an involuntarily or a
coerced share or pool would be a subject
to a wage adjustment where we would then
redistribute we'd say to the employer
you have to pay back all of the
employees all of that money those are
actually very significant when we do a
wage adjustment and you go back a year
those adjustments usually are pretty
significant in addition to the wage
adjustment there would be penalties
again we do see coercion at times I'd
Echo Mr reedy's comments that most often
I think all employers are usually well
intentioned and they're usually looking
to maintain peace but we have certainly
come across instances in which there
have been a coercive environment again
someone saying you can't work here
unless you do that someone's saying do
this at the end of the shift and then
the person says they don't want to and
then they get called again and they said
you're sure you don't want to so we we
do come across that I would say that the
language put forth here I do thank the
hospitality folks for having provided us
with the language and opportunity to
work with them on on some of the
language we do view this language as
maintaining the intent mainly or mainly
that there would be still this notion
that it has to be voluntary and cannot
be coerced the only other question I'm
remembering off the top of my head uh
representative Cahill you had made the
comment about how something would be
designated service charge if
an employer looked at this change and
said we are no longer going to be
providing service charges
to those employees the one thing we
would look at is we'd say okay those are
no longer directly tipped employees so
they're they would no longer be subject
to a sub minimum wage or anything like
that so I just want to be clear that if
an employer is not giving the tips over
then that employee is no longer directly
tipped so again that would result in a
change and I do uh recognize Mr Summer's
comments that yes we have come across
instances in which the service charge is
being held against the employer and
they're being taxed upon it by the IRS
so it has an issue that has come up from
time to time
so I'm happy to take any questions
for a Deputy Commissioner Ogden
uh representative colcum
thank you Mr chair and thank you um
Deputy Commissioner I'd like to visit
this service charge versus TIP
ingratuity my understanding is a service
charge is something that I would be
required to pay where typic gratuity is
something that I can do at my own
discretion
so if a service charge is put on a bill
then
wouldn't it be the income to the
employer and not uh and then basically
an expense back to an employee if that's
the way that they were choosing to
distribute it
so two things I would say there there
are I think times in which particular
employers have used the term
synonymously I would agree with you that
in a general sense a service charge is
usually a specified amount or a
specified percentage I do think and I'm
not an IRS expert but I do think that is
why the IRS has probably characterized
it differently and they did make that
change so I don't know that I'm
answering your question but I would say
that
um yes generally service charges are a
specified amount I do think that is why
it's looked at is less speculative than
a gratuity and it's directly
characterizes income to the business I
believe that's why the arist did that
representative McKenzie
thank you Mr chairman
uh
where is this uh where is this noticed
in uh in restaurants is a requirement
that that there'd be some posting of the
law as it relates to tip pooling and tip
sharing
so there is requirements related to the
posting for minimum wage but no there's
not a specific requirement I believe
that the tip pooling statute 26b I don't
I there is not a specific requirement
that that be individually posted thank
you
huh
any further questions for Deputy
Commissioner Ogden
I have a couple as always
um
why are we changing this now since it
has been in effect a number of years
speak for them but I think the
hospitality industry came forward in
this instance because we have had a
couple of uh cases over the course of
the last year where this specific issue
when I say this specific issue this idea
of
an employer there was some question
about when or if it came up and in the
context of working through those cases
the department was asked well are you
saying it would be a violation just if
the employee or brought the idea up and
it wasn't coercive and being very candid
my answer was that if you look at the
way the language is crafted now an
employer bringing it up first would be
or should be seen as or could be seen as
a violation of that law I don't believe
that was the intent of this I do think
and I hope that the department
undertaking these cases has always paid
more attention to whether there's been
coercion or not but if we're we're
speaking plainly and being candid the
way the law is presently crafted an
employer bringing up the concept first
without being prompted by the employee
that would be could be cited as a
violation so I believe again I don't
mean to speak for them but I believe
that has come up we had that discussion
and I think that was the impetus for
saying well we want to clarify the
language
I understand that part of it um and
thank you for clarifying um the other
part of it is if you're in a large
corporation
and um let's say it's the front of the
house manager is doing the interviews
would they be considered the employer if
they mention that they have uh tip
sharing or tip pooling there again
whoever the employers yeah in that
context I believe that it would be
looked at is that that person would be
the would be the employer yes
thank you
representative colcom
thank you I'm curious
um
tipping seems to have expanded quite a
bit and we talk a lot about the sub
minimum wage and this is specific to sub
minimum wage
but when you go into other stores that
are
not perceived to be restaurants and
there's a tip jar there
um is there any regulation as to how
those tips are handled are can those be
pooled or does that not fall into any of
this and they can be handled under any
way they want no the issue there and I
believe Mr summer spoke to this when you
have an environment like a
and Dunkin Donuts but when you have an
environment when there is a jar out and
and people are using that to put
gratuities in it we would ultimately
look at that and say okay who does that
tip belong to I think in practice most
often those are looked at as pools
because it would be impossible to say
you know who owns what percentage or
portion of that when I talk to employers
about that particular scenario I would
say yes in practice that is probably
going to be treated as a pool but if you
have a particular employee who says no I
know that that ten dollars was thrown in
for me
arguably they could bring a wage claim
of some type that would not be something
the department would pursue because
again we would look at a tip jar
difficult to trace ownership to we would
look at that in practice as a pool but I
would advise employers a particular
employee or particular employees could
try and assert individual ownership over
the gratuity so apologies for if I'm
rambling on and on but I would say in
short we would say that tips are tips if
it's a tip it belongs to the employees
who perform the service and the
environment you're talking about it's
sometimes difficult to trace who owns
what portion we would probably see that
or treat that as a pool
so then it doesn't matter that that
employee is not a sub-minimum wage
employee no you could have um you could
have an employer an employer decide that
they want and we do have some um and Mr
Summers can speak to this as well we do
have employers who pay uh directly
tipped employees in excess of minimum
wage they they do do that it's what
determines uh if they get the tip it's
theirs
whether they're paid some minimum or not
any further questions for the Deputy
Commissioner
thank you thank you
can we get the blue sheet and the online
um things I think representative
seaworth will take care of that
um close the hearing on 269.
so we had no one sign in in person
um on the blue sheet online there was
one single sign-in in opposition to the
bill hmm
next up
uh I will open the hearing on SB 46
relative to electronic payments to
employee debit cards I have
um
one card so far if there are other
people planning to speak please fill the
cars get them turned in and this is Kate
Littman representing representing
Senator Carson who is the Prime sponsor
of the bill
so
uh good morning my name is Kate Lipman
I'm the Senate majority policy director
I am here to introduce Senate Bill 46 on
behalf of Senator Carson
improved technology enables employees to
be paid more consistently and securely a
wage payment law modernization is needed
to permit employers to pay wages
electronically it can be impossible for
employers to comply with wage payment
laws if they must offer paper checks
too often employees who receive paper
checks can't get paid on payday if
there's a snowstorm or other issues
preventing travel to the workplace of
banks
offering electronic wage payments such
as choice of direct deposit or debit
card will would eliminate this concern
Most states are already doing this as 93
of American workers are paid via direct
deposit in the 31 states that allow
direct deposit there have been no
complaints debit cards offer far better
consumer protections and convenience
than checks employees are able to choose
between direct deposit or debit cards at
any time and those who do prefer a paper
check would still have that option
in the event that an employee is unable
to access their wages from a debit card
the employer would provide a replacement
card check direct deposit or cash and
would still remain liable for failing to
pay wages on time
thank you for the opportunity to speak
today I'll defer any questions to those
behind me if there are any who wish to
speak on the bill and if there aren't
any I'm happy to pass along any
questions to Senator Carson and get that
back to you all right thank you very
much for your testimony can we get a
copy of do you do you have a written
copy that you can turn in
or email
uh afterward if you don't it has my
notes on is that okay
that's fine you're fine with that thank
you
the other uh just before you step away
and I'll ask the question although you
don't have to answer it I'll I'll leave
it out there um for other people
testifying you mentioned that 31 States
have a requirement for direct deposit
and I'm wondering if that number is
different for those that require
um employees except a payroll card or a
debit card if direct deposit is not
available
I can certainly find that out from you
from Senator Carson let you know all
right thank you thank you very much any
other questions
seeing none thank you very much
next up I have Pete eisberg
representing ADP
um he is speaking in support of the bill
and I think your micro there how's that
sorry thank you Mr chairman and
committee members we appreciate the
opportunity to speak on behalf of Senate
Bill 46 this bill would permit employers
to offer electronic pay to employees it
would just remove the requirement that
employers also offer a paper paycheck
option to employees
that's that what has been adopted in I
think now 32 states that permit
employers to just offer either direct
deposit or payroll cards 93 of workers
today already get paid through direct
deposit
so it's a relatively small percentage
that are still relying on paper
paychecks but paper checks are really
not a very good option it's it's
um the difficulty we we really came to
light with cogid when businesses were
shut down there was nobody to accept
paper paychecks when we wanted to
deliver them we couldn't get there in
the first place because travel was shut
down but it's really very normal it's
you know every year we have snow storms
or
um some other reason that you just can't
get paychecks to the workplace or God
forbid somebody is sick they can't get
to work to pick up a check or they're
traveling or on vacation if they're not
there to get up take up the physical
paper paycheck they don't get paid
and that happens routinely and it really
shouldn't it shouldn't we've become used
to it but it shouldn't be normal and
acceptable for employers not to pay
employees if there's inconvenient in any
way so this bill would resolve that
electronic pay resolves that concern
altogether
um you know as mentioned it's much
better for employees there was a federal
regulations uh Consumer Financial
Protection board in 2019 issued
regulations on prepaid cards that added
lots and lots of good consumer
protections the um the fraud protections
protections against fraud unauthorized
use as a dispute resolution associated
with these cards they can't be
overdrafted there's no NSF fees possible
with these cards
um
and current law already requires that
employers provide a free way for
employees to you know if they want cash
to take these cards to a nearby uh look
you know bank or other facility and
exchange you know get the full value on
the card for cash if they want to so
that's possible and it's easy to do that
you can go to literally any of the large
retailers Costco or Kroger or Walmart
any of the large retailers will do that
as well
it also includes you know free savings
features so you you know if you're an
employee you have one of these cards
it's easy for you to say well I'm just
going to set up a free sidebar account
for vacation savings for Christmas
savings for my you can give a card to
your daughter who's in college and
that's her spending account so a lot of
good things there
um and really it's the way that
everybody's getting paid nowadays it's
um you know if you're getting a
government payment any government
benefit is electronic Social Security
um disability unemployment insurance
nutrition assistance all that is
electronic
um all government employees are
typically paid electronically and it's
really only the private sector workers
that are still um you know kind of stuck
with a requirement to offer
pay-per-paychecks for those who who want
it but you know I think it should be up
to the employer like if it's important
to employees and they really like their
paper paychecks employers are certainly
free to continue doing that we just
don't think it's necessary to have a
state law requirement that employers
offer paper paychecks and we'd resolve a
lot of problems and anyway so I'll stop
there I'm glad to answer your questions
I appreciate the opportunity thank you
thank you for your testimony I do have a
question most in your testimony you
emphasize the advantages for the
employee
as you said though
the employee can request the paper check
or not so I would think
what are the advantages from the terms
of the employer as in state law that is
where the Restriction currently
resides right for the employer's
perspective it would be a lot easier
simpler less expensive because they
don't have to if they don't want to they
can just offer electronic and they don't
have to have the whole system set up to
keep track of receive and distribute
paper paychecks every pay period it's a
costly thing to do
thank you other questions and
representative of the line
oh did you have your hand up
thank you representative Granger
thank you
um will this uh would this bill hasten
the adoption of Central Bank digital
currencies
I'm sorry I didn't quite get that would
it Hasting the adoption of uh Central
Bank digital currencies
uh no it has no impact or no effect on
digital currencies this is um
you know it's just it's like direct
deposit but it's to a you know a debit
card like any other debit card there's
mine it's a VISA branded or a MasterCard
branded debit card
but in terms of like crypto
follow-up
uh so when when so does the company
issue these debit cards
and are there or are they are the debit
cards for a specific bank that they're
paying through
um the company typically hires a payroll
firm the payroll firm would offer um
either direct deposit or debit cards and
of course payroll checks
um but the payroll company would arrange
with a bank to issue these cards and the
bank would be the issuer and
administrator of the the card accounts
if that helps okay
but if there's any problem the employee
always goes back to the employer and the
employer's responsible they have to make
sure that the employee is paid and that
things are working and they get their
answers if they have questions
one more follow-up
uh thank you so assuming an employee
does want to paper check or a cash
payment maybe they're concerned about
the privacy of having all their records
in an electronic form uh for whatever
reason
um this bill would basically make it so
that if a large company
for instance a Fortune 500 company
if they don't want to provide a paper
check then they wouldn't have to is that
correct yes okay
thank you
representative colcum
um so with the debit card there is a
bank behind that that's managing the
funds that are coming in from the
employer yes there are FDIC insured
Banks um like yeah
exactly
well card is misplaced
uh then those funds are still available
yes it's very easy very fast you can
actually instant issue a card from the
employer's office to to anybody who
loses their card and print a new one in
the next few days kind of thing so it's
that's something that's very easy to
resolve and the funds of course are
protected
well
um the funds are you know the card is
theirs the account is theirs they can
continue they can take that card
actually to another employer and ask the
employer to just continue depositing
directly to that cart so it's a
functional equivalent of a bank account
really
I'm sorry will fees then be imposed when
he leaves that employer for maintaining
that account or will they continue to be
not imposed because it was a paycheck
debit card system
um I don't know if there's a law against
that or if that's in the regulation e
the the prepaid card but I my impression
is that there are no fees um if somebody
leaves an employer and continues to use
the account elsewhere
there's there's very few fees that
actually apply the only way that you get
charged fees with these cards nowadays
is if you just for convenience if you
have we want to use an ATM that's nearby
as opposed to you know finding one that
is free that is one of the surcharge
free ones or again going to a major
retailer all those are free but part of
the
system is you know you actually have a
phone app on your smartphone and you can
just bring it up and say where's the
nearest free ATM it's very quick and
it'll tell you exactly where to go to to
find an ATM that has no fees
representative
thank you just to follow up on
representative's question fees do you
get charge of fee every time you use the
card no matter what you're doing or is
this something that
you know just like a typical credit card
no I mean any fees are disclosed again
again under the federal law regulation
requires all fees to be disclosed in
advance to card holders and and
basically the only fee you know you it
prohibits most fees like the the swipe
if you're actually using it as a debit
card to pay for your groceries or pay
for anything or online making a purchase
there are no fees for that uh really the
only fee is if um you go to an out of
network ATM because it's convenient it's
the one that's right next to you as
opposed to wherever it is
right yeah I understand that can can I
follow up please oh I just heard you
know in the past that these this system
has really been detrimental to employees
over the years that somehow they get
to use a term user or earlier screwed
when they use this stuff then I and you
know obviously a lot of people live
paycheck to paycheck we don't want to
see anybody getting unnecessary fees or
even losing that balance
over if a certain amount of time has
passed
you know maybe they didn't need the
money for a few weeks so they didn't use
the card
is that money still there and it just
keeps getting topped off every week is
is that how it works yes exactly the
employer just adds to it every pay
period and those monies don't go away
there's no fees that take funds out of
the account uh uh there's no maintenance
fees or anything like that um uh from
when you mentioned and I think you're
referring to there was a pretty negative
article in New York Times in like 2014
called pinch by plastic which really
brought a lot of attention to this and
resulted in the Federal Regulation that
eliminated all of those fees and and
really resolve the issue again that was
2019 we really have not heard complaints
since then
all right thank you thank you
representative Drago
thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question
I own a small business I we don't
utilize this
um but I'm sure there are other small
businesses that do and I happen to be
driving this morning with my business
partner and I shared with him how you
know we replaced the cards and all that
his response was we'd be replacing the
cards every day
um
depending on the industry you're in a
lot of times you have I guess not so
responsible employees uh and we see it
with our gas cards all the time they'll
get lost we always have to call the bank
and get canceled and get new ones
replaced there's a line in here that
says if an employee debit card is lost
stolen or damaged such that the funds
are no longer accessible the employee
the employer shall provide the employee
with their placement within 24 hours
if he calls me on a Friday night and we
have 14 employees and they they were out
for the night they lost it or whatever
am I blocking off or any employer there
I have to block off their entire weekend
now to replace the cards we don't I I'm
just curious as to how that works
because in my situation I don't have
office staff 24 hours a day to do this
what do those employers do
uh that is a good question I'm not
really sure
um
you know I I think any employee can call
the card company itself of it you know
again if they don't have a card they
don't have the phone number necessarily
but if they can call the employer and
figure out you know who the issuer is
they can call and just get a replacement
card and then the card company would
handle the issuance again typically um
if you're working with the payroll
company we we provide a a stock of maybe
10 cards just for instant issue so that
if that doesn't happen you can just turn
around open your you know desk door and
issue another card instantly but
weekends um yeah it's a good question
I'm not quite sure how that would work
if the employer is not available and the
employee's not sure who to call
follow-up
so that that was that was my main
question about that but then I guess
they could call the maybe they could
text me and I could just give them the
I'm sure all the card numbers are the
same on the back to call losses stolen
whatever yeah
if they call and for whatever reason
wherever you get the card from the bank
or whatever they're not open who's
responsible that situation is it me
having to come back to pay them cash or
do we just say yeah you're gone for the
weekend and the bank's not open I have
to wait till Monday who's responsible in
that situation that could be difficult
there is a line in the bill that says
that you know if employees have
difficulties
um you know getting access to their
funds that the employer has to issue as
you mentioned uh you know some sort of
replacement cash card or check within 24
hours so that may be a a concern for
small businesses yes
representative Susie thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking the
question just real quick somebody that
doesn't do banking at all for whatever
purposes gets this debit card is it they
go to the ATM is there a limit on the
ATM
that they'll be able to withdraw so
let's say somebody's got a thousand
dollars they want to take out can they
go to the ATM take a thousand dollars
outward do you know of any ATMs that
have mac uh maximums that they allow
people to take out at one time yes it's
actually a good question and there's a
related issue which is what if I have
321 dollars and 18 cents and I want all
of it you know the ATM is not going to
give you that but the answer I think is
to you walk into any bank that has a
Visa or MasterCard logo on the window
which is virtually all of them and go to
the teller and say I'd like the full
amount on this card and they are
obligated they're required to pay the
full amount in cash without a fee
but it does involve walking into a bank
and talking to a teller
um
representative Granger has another
question you want me to go first oh uh
ah sorry represent Broody thank you Mr
chairman
um first of all I didn't get your name
or who you represent I'm sorry I'm my
name is Pete Iceberg I'm vice president
of government relations for ADP ADP is
the largest payroll company in the
nation we we pay one out of every six
U.S workers
okay thank you now you mentioned
something about changing employers
you're still going to use that same card
or do you get a new card you can use the
same card so if you don't have a
conventional bank account and you'd like
to continue continue getting your
paychecks electronically you could just
tell the employer your your bank account
number associated with the card and that
is your they just make deposits into the
card as if nothing had changed
so you're like follow-up follow-up yeah
so you're not like a third party you're
like a fourth party you've got the
employer the employee some banks
involved and then there's you
is that what
well I mean
uh payroll companies are involved in you
know calculating the paychecks and
issuing the paychecks and the paycheck
and check stubs and W-2s and things like
that so we offer the the payroll cards
and we work with banks to to do it the
banks are the actually the
administrators but that's not a change
from how it works today there's there's
always been employers payroll companies
Banks and employees
but you're using this like as a credit
card or debit card it's a debit card
yeah but another mancaster service that
was a debit card service
um this is a yeah the debit card is a is
an account Arrangement that they offer
again carefully controlled with fees
disclosed in advance and so forth
so all right thank you
representative Cahill
thank you Mr Sharon thank you Mr
Weisberg Iceberg thank you thank you
um so you said that many of the fees are
gone after all that bad press uh among
them would it be the uh the fee that
happens after you after one transaction
if you go to the bank and take out half
of your paycheck is there still is there
a fee for your next transaction
um that's a good question there can be
um I mean the employers are required to
and these cards are required to
um permit somebody to take uh a
transaction for the full amount of the
card but if they want to you know spread
it out and take multiple transactions
and withdraw a certain amount over a
number of days there could be
transactions on the second third and so
forth but
um again in any event it's always free
if you just walk into a teller and say
give me uh X dollars
follow up and the most the ATMs that we
have out there are in network so they
don't charge a fee so even if it's a
second or third there's no fee for those
transactions
um I I believe I recall balance inquiry
fees have they been eliminated by
Congress
um the cfpb rule I believe did eliminate
that and it required that these cards
offer a free means of multiple free
means of checking your account balance
it's always a I'm always like I have a
Starbucks card and I never know how much
is on it so everybody needs to know
swiping or phone uh that can call a
phone number or you can check your phone
app but
or use an ATM there can be no fee for
checking your balance amount
follow-up
and who makes the money when you when
all these cards are out there being used
you know in restaurants and stores who's
who's making the swipe fees is that is
does ADP have a piece of that I believe
so yes yes so we get a small fraction of
the transaction fees the swipe fees as
you say it pays for a lot and those
those are paid for by retailers and such
whoever is receiving the payment right
and little things add up yeah so so
these little things add up to quite a
bit which is why you keep on coming back
uh be careful that your questions are
questions and uh right okay so would you
believe that that these fees are a
strong motivation for this legislation
to be coming back to us every two years
um
I was here last year for the first time
but um I would say no our primary
motivation adp's primary motivation is
that we had such a difficult time under
covet and delivering paper paychecks to
businesses that were closed and you know
people that literally couldn't get paid
that we started to pay a lot of
attention not you know also ESG concerns
uh environmental concerns started to to
ramp up in our thinking that delivering
and printing all this paper was very
very costly and
so that's our primary concern
is not the not the revenue there's not a
lot of money to be made in the swipe
fees
really okay
thank you thank you representative
McKenzie
thank you Mr chairman I some of this may
be better in front of uh Rudy but
so under the current scenario
um
if cash employers people who normally
get paid by cash
the employee can now go to the employee
and say no we're not going to pay you by
cash it's going to be electronic
correct
uh yes uh it could be I think most
employers would just usually apply this
on a prospective basis for new hires
after a certain date they would get
electronic follow-up
um there are a number of employees who
[Music]
go to check cashing services
specifically to send money to families
around the country around the world
the debit cards
can you go to a check cashing company
and use a debit card such as yours you
could there would probably be a fee
associated with that I think that the
debit cards were really intended to
avoid the check cashers
but if somebody wanted to use them to
move money overseas or something then
they could certainly do that and one
final question
uh what if you don't have a bank account
at all and you don't have an ID right
driver's license
sure um if you were able to get a job
the employer can issue you a debit card
and that is a functional equivalent of a
bank account so you essentially have a
bank account even if you don't have the
ID that Banks normally would ask for
thank you thank you and I'm going to go
around before I come back start the
second question round uh over here and
then I'll come back to you
representative Granger
uh thank you Mr Mr chair so I buy a
ridiculous amount of guns and a
ridiculous amount of ammo and one thing
that we've been noticing lately in the
firearm Community is that a lot of
electronic Banks and electronic
Financial Services providers will refuse
to engage in transactions for perfectly
legal activities we're also seeing this
in other states that have legalized
certain drugs certain banks are
unwilling to engage in those practices
so would this legis I don't so I see
that there are certain protections if
employees are unable to access their
funds does that also extend if the bank
this uh whoever is backing this debit
card doesn't want to provide the money
for certain transactions
um that's a good question I'm really not
sure how that works or what types of
businesses might be blocked from the
electronic banking system other
marijuana distributorships might be a
good example
um
so I'm not that may be an issue
thank you
representative and thank you Mr chairman
so people who have automatic deductions
every month
they would deduct from here like they
would at debit card like child support
um
I I give to
um like the children's hospitals they
take a check a little bit every month
that would come out of this just like
they would take it out of my debit card
account yes exactly you still receive if
you have a debit card as your form of
payment you still receive a statement of
deductions which tells you you know the
amount of hours that you had and your
your pay rate and the gross amount you
received in the taxes amount this that
were deducted in any you know voluntary
deductions and things like that so you
still get that statement you get that
electronically and it's you know pretty
easy to deal with as well
thank you
representative online
thank you Mr chairman um this is the
second time we've seen this and um
it still has the same problems that we
had the last time
um so if you have you worked with the
proponents to get this language changed
from our last iteration of this or is
this just the same retread that we're
going to look at again
um there is a slight revision to it but
I'm not really recalling um and I'm not
sure it was ever elaborated what the
concerns were with a bill we were a
little surprised that it was not
approved
but I never really understood why
okay
um so I would just follow our little
latitude Mr chairman
a little bit
um the debit cards that you speak of
those issued by your company that are
backed by a bank that you do business
with is that correct yeah so it's not
technically the employee's bank account
um it's the employees account though as
much as any bank account belongs to any
person that has a bank account
so they would be required to show ID to
the bank issuing bank and everything
else in order to have that account
I'm sorry say it again when I walk into
an open an account I have to show ID
fill up paperwork and everything else
and that's my bank account right if an
employer is issuing a debit card that
it's not drawn on the Employees bank
right um yeah there is uh if you want to
take this card and make it
um portable
um so you can accept deposits from other
than the employer you can do that but
you do have to walk into a bank and show
ID and they you know basically upgrade
the card to permit
um portability
but you know if all you're doing is
receiving uh payments of wages from the
employer there's really no need to show
identification or you know get verified
through the know your customer kind of
regime through
the banks
if that makes sense it does
um and I'll get to the and the fees
that'll follow up Mr chairman the fees
that are associated with that as well if
they don't use it for portability and
they use it as a checking account but
basically it's not their checking
account they're using it to draw funds
through your account
is there fees associated with that and
the The Limited availability for those
funds
no I mean these um the net amount of
wages are deposited onto these card
accounts and you know they can be used
in whatever way there's uh free bill
payment services you could access online
to to make payments from your card
account for example or withdraw cash or
you know use it like a debit card at a
retailer
there's no fee for any of that okay and
so this is basically this is tailored
for your company which is ADP which is a
large multi
Nationwide company what about the mama
Pops that don't offer this
um they can certainly continue to offer
paper checks and they were not requiring
employers to um to stop offering paper
checks we're just saying that employers
prefer to pay electronically they should
be able to do it
protects we discontinued
no no no the paper checks would continue
to be offered for if any in for example
if you have a collective bargaining
agreement any employer that has a cab
would probably just continue offering
paper checks because they you know they
wouldn't want to make that a an issue to
negotiate with the Union
but any employer can just continue
offering paper checks if they wanted to
since I'm getting a look I'll say
something having heard this bill a
number of times that hopefully is
clarifying what this change would do is
it's on the employee and what the
employee can demand
so it doesn't affect what the employer
can offer and if the employee an
employer agree to any of the allowed
payments that can continue
what this changes is right now if there
is no agreement between employer and
employee the employee can demand a paper
check and the employer must offer that
this would remove that requirement
and allow
in lieu of a paper check the employer
could say you know what I'm not gonna I
don't offer that paper check
if you if you don't have a bank account
we do electronic deposit if you don't
have a bank account then the payroll
card is your option
so I hope that is clarifying for the new
people and I hope that doesn't conflict
with oh
thank you all right
um I have a question and it's I I heard
you mentioned something that we talked
about last year and so if you could
clarify for the new people so
if I have direct deposit I might get a
paper uh
form in the mail that tells me what was
deposited what was deducted in the case
of a payroll card particularly one
that's trying to avoid that exchange of
paper how does that work how does the
the
information for the employer about what
he or she has been paid get transmitted
right with each pay period every
employee continues to get a pay
statement that says hey for this last
two weeks you worked these hours you
were paid this gross amount and here are
your deductions the taxes and other
deductions so the way that they get that
is through their employer portal
typically it's electronic it's it's
hosted on a secure website which is
pretty easy for employees to deal with
they already use these portals to for
example enroll in benefits and and you
know receive a lot of other
Communications from the employer their
form W-2 things like that it's all
posted electronically it's very
helpful from the perspective of
employees don't have to keep track of
paper which they often lose they can
just you know if they need something two
or three years from now they can go back
and say well you know let me just look
up on the portal to get my W-2 from 2000
or my pay statement from December and
it's all there for them but those same
statements are available those are also
available for former employees
the the systems were designed to permit
you know ongoing access to anybody who
was previously an employee and has those
records for for easy access
all right thank you uh we have some
other follow-up questions I'll start
over here again represent Broody thank
you Mr chairman so
if this isn't a bank
it's probably not insured by the FDIC
um it is a bank in the these cards must
be insured by the FDIC at cardholder
level
so yes they are in FDIC insured well and
what level is that if I if I don't spend
all my money every week and I have a
nice Nest Egg there and somebody walks
off with it all I've seen a big company
do that if the bank fails FDIC will
cover um up to 250 000 and they just a
couple weeks ago uh expanded that
dramatically for Silicon Valley Bank and
and Signature Bank
thank you
representative Cahill thank you Mr
chairman and thank you uh so if this
bill were to pass then accepting either
the uh the the digit the card or uh a a
bank account in your own direct deposit
that becomes a condition of employment
um yes essentially yes
yeah thank you
representative McKenzie
could you uh
Define what what network means and how
to network in network
um okay and think about it I think in
terms of the State of New Hampshire many
places where there was not a whole lot
around right so
no it's a good question it's a point to
confusion for everyone
um like if you look at the back of any
debit card it'll show like uh the
networks that it's associated with like
Allpoint and star and others and if you
see go to an ATM they have logos of all
the networks that they're associated
with so you know it's it's
you have to look at the card to see what
network you're in understand
um you know where which are you facing
an ATM that is in that Network and if so
there's no fee and again there's a an
easy Bank app that you can just look up
and say where's the free their nearest
free ATM and it'll show you exactly
where you can go to to be in in network
so a person needs a phone
they need to be able to access portals
they need to be able to go to the phone
to find out what the ATM machines are
and then they run the risk of um of not
being in a network if they are in some
place in remote New Hampshire correct
yes that's true and again you could
assuming there's a bank available they
can walk into any bank and just ask for
the full amount in cash but otherwise
yeah the employer oftentimes for for
people who you know are just not
computer savvy they don't usually work
with computers at all uh employers will
usually have a kiosk or some means for
to go into the office when they visit to
print anything that they want look
things up and that sort of thing
representative Leclair
thanks
just to follow up on a couple of my
representative colleagues here
about the ID thing and and
say I found a card
I didn't know what the balance was I'm
going to walk into a bank Yep this is my
card if I don't have to show ID or
anything they're just gonna
cash up for me
yeah they're required to
um but it's a good question I mean if I
was a bank teller I kind of want to see
ID I guess yeah and I get that but you
kind of said that you didn't I'm sorry
follow up if I could but you kind of
said that um it wasn't necessary
necessary yeah the um essentially the
banks are deferring to employers to
issue these cards to to say that these
you know employees have been vetted that
they know who they are that they're you
know U.S citizens eligible for
employment
um and so the issue occurred on that
basis but they're not portable cards
they can't accept deposits from other
sources other than the employer unless
they walk into a bank with ID and get it
verified
yeah and I understand that that's for a
deposit what if I just want to cash it
if I found one of my Representatives
wallets and stole it and took it and you
know I'm not the nicest person in the
world and I just try to cash a check or
cash my debit card out yeah this is me
this is me Bob Smith right here you know
I don't have my ID with me and this is
who I work for and I suspect you're
right if you walked into a bank that you
didn't have an account in and they
didn't know you and they'd probably
asking for ID yes and you're saying
though that it wasn't be necessary uh
it's not necessary for issuance of the
card but yeah if you if you just found a
card on the sidewalk
um yeah you may have difficulty actually
using it yeah but and that's I
appreciate that and I'd like that to
happen but it didn't sound like that was
the case yeah it said
for the purposes of issuing the card
versus in front of a check uh bank
teller who may be a different question
you probably need ID
thank you thank you representative
going back to
sorry I got distracted I apologize so
thank you for taking my question going
back to the issue of
um separation with employer
currently with an HSA account I
separated from my employer
I now have to cover the fees on that HSA
account for managing that account
because I'm no longer with that employer
so my concern with this card is if I
separate from that employer and I choose
not to go back to work I'm retired or
whatever at what point in time if ever
is there going to be a charge for them
to manage my account because there's no
longer money coming in from the employer
from on my behalf for that account
um I don't believe there are ever any
fees for that I mean these are just
don't believe yeah I see it
well another question if I may
um
shifting years
how how many reports do you guys have
any data on how many reports there are
of stolen cards lost cards money that's
not available so I've gone to the
grocery store to try to get my money and
the grocery store says I don't have
enough to give you so I can't get my
money from a grocery store do you guys
have data are you collecting data and
trending what the reports are on these
cards
we do have some pretty uh detailed
statistics on card usage and how people
are using the cards
um so I'd be glad to
um you know take that back and and
provide any information if you have
specific
uh points you want to ask about
well I would I would like to know not so
much the usage of the cards but how many
of those cards are are on uh the money
is unavailable to the employees or how
many of the cards have been lost and
people have had a hard time getting them
replaced
um I'd like to know the data on how
difficult that money has been for
employees to capture okay
thank you
other question
I don't see any other questions
so thank you very much for your
testimony thank you
next up I have just one final card so if
there was anyone else uh intending to
testify please fill out a pink card and
get that handed in the final card is
from Deputy Commissioner Rudy Ogden from
the Department of Labor he is neither in
support or opposed to this bill
just happy to answer any questions if I
if no one has questions all right so I'm
sure there are
and uh
representative your hand came up so
quick you have to go first thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Deputy
Commissioner
um so uh representative Granger brought
up a a great Point earlier about um if
it's a certain bank that doesn't allow a
certain processes through a certain
processing of debits to go through uh
based on their ESG or whatever they're
doing if it's marijuana
Firearms liquor anything like that
um would that be considered a processing
defect on behalf of the bank and payroll
company and then is the employer rely
now liable for the remainder of that
wages do not from the Department's
perspective if I'm understanding the
question uh correctly the department
would look at this law and and with this
change is saying essentially uh that
really what the employer is on the hook
for is making sure that a card provided
the person being paid via payroll card
has means of accessing their wages
without a fee if I understood the
scenario from representative Granger
that you've just
kind of come back to you're talking
about doing purchases with the card in
other types of transactions again we
would be looking specifically were the
wages there was the person able to
access the money in in terms of take it
in hand without a fee if if purchases
were blocked we would not look at that
as an interruption of their wages
if that makes sense thank you and follow
up Mr chairman uh Mr chairman
um the 24 hours
notification and then 24 hours to be
replaced
representative Draco great off a great
Point earlier and I want to reiterate
that for
um employee loses their card at midnight
on Friday
you know ADP is closed checkmates closed
every all the big guys are closed
they're not going to get a car until
Monday
how is that going to relate to the
employer as presently drafted we would
look at this and saying within 24 hours
of being notified now we I guess in
given situations we could say when did
the notification actually happen but we
would look at the present languages
saying within 24 hours of being notified
a card will be reissued I would
highlight for that and I actually
appreciate the inclusion of that
language in there I've been at the
Department of Labor about 10 years now
and I will say in my time in the
department this has been the biggest
issue relative to payroll cards
certainly we've heard about unbanked
individuals and fees passed on to folks
but the biggest issue that the
department has seen relative to employee
complaints and payroll cards at least in
my tenure at the department has been
instances in which individuals have had
processing problems where they they're
not trying to make a purchase or it's
not that they're trying to make multiple
purchases and there's fees their issue
has been I'm not able to access it and
where we have had some difficulties is
that there have been employers who have
then said deal with the card company
don't deal with me and that's why again
I do appreciate the inclusion of the
fact that here it is very clearly on the
employer that we would be looking for
the employer to make that right in the
immediate I I do take the point that 24
hours on a weekend does present I
understand your your concern that that
could present issues as presently
drafted we would say within 24 hours of
being notified the employer should be
taking action on that well
I could I follow up on that question
because
so
as I see it there could be there's many
levels of different organizations that
come between the employee the employer
and the cash in hand
and
you answered an earlier question that
you're mostly concerned that the
employer has made that cash available
but the issue of the employee getting
that cash could be the bank that has the
Visa sticker on their window that is now
honoring some other bank's payroll card
which if I understood the previous
testimony was all
federally regulated
so
how might the New Hampshire Department
of Labor get involved with let's say the
person who brings their payroll card
into the bank the bank wanted ID that
the person didn't have available and
said well now I can't get my pay because
this bank is not giving it to me at what
point can the State Department of Labor
get involved if the person is not able
to access their wages without a fee we
would say that that's a violation okay
so and independent of at what point in
the process that inability was generated
correct okay
thank you for letting me please jump in
and follow up thank you for the
follow-up
um so we replaced the card in 24 hours
say they they call you at you know seven
o'clock on a Friday night we replace a
Saturday morning that guy's not going to
be live till Monday morning
how is that replacing how is that going
to be able to replace those wages since
the Banking Company all the payroll
companies will be closed until that time
on Monday morning
I I imagine there are pot that that
might be a scenario in which there'd be
issue there could be other scenarios in
which that language might be deemed
problematic again I believe the intent
of that language is to just highlight
the fact that when there is an issue the
employer is being looked at to correct
it in the immediate uh to your point yes
if it's not ultimately Avail if the card
the language says that they'll be
provided a replacement card within 24
hours they would have to meet that
okay and you've noticed something I'll
be back representative Cahill
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Ogden I want to sort of piggyback on uh
representative colcom's question
uh with do you have a record I know you
said anecdotally that you know what you
saw what you're most familiar with is
what they they can't get the the money
do you have any any sort of record of
other infractions on how many and how
well how frequently they happen people
having trouble with these cards
I can look to see what we have
specifically I don't have that at hand I
would say that it's not a frequent issue
and again most often when it comes up it
is individuals who are not able to
access it so our folks on intake will
get a call they're being told hey I have
this card I can't access it you know no
one's helping me
um and and we we work through that again
it's not frequent I can see what data
they have relative to the number of
those calls
um but again that is the issue that most
often comes up uh in terms of a a
complaint to the department thank you a
follow-up
and thank you for that and again if this
should pass then the willingness to
accept the payroll card becomes a
condition of employment is that your
understanding
um yes they would have to offer direct
deposit first if the individual doesn't
have a bank account or does not provide
their bank account information it would
then go to a payroll card and and to
your point that would be yes you want to
work here and be paid you're on one of
those platforms
thank you
representative McKenzie thank you
uh if I uh as an employer uh send out a
check and the check is bad
there's some legal
uh recalls employees have it's against
the law you can't do that is this the
same environment that we that this these
cods exist in if the employer does not
deposit the money on Thursday afternoon
so the employee can access it are they
under any kind of liability if the card
comes up short
if the money's not in the account as
opposed to giving somebody a check I
can't speak specifically to criminal
liability that they may face or other
types of liability they would be have
liability with the Department in terms
of we would look that at that as if
they're not processing payment promptly
or in full that would be a violation and
we would say those monies are owed and
there could be civil penalties through
the department I I'll I don't know if
there's other violations for
underfunding uh payroll uh payroll cards
and I would say that it would we would
view checks the same as when people pay
via check if there's a if it can't be
cashed again we don't take criminal
action we would view that as a violation
of labor law for not paying in full
um and there be liability for that
through us again I can't we don't handle
the criminal aspect of that
thank you
are there other questions representative
avaloni thank you Mr chairman and thank
you again uh commissioner Artin um
on the employer side
um
if the employer does not offer a payroll
account let's say they're using a
mom-and-pop only issues only has the
three money check or electronic transfer
are they mandated now under this to
provide a payroll card if somebody
declines all those three options no
my reading of this doesn't change the
fact that the employer would still have
the option to say I want to pay via cash
or or check
so once and uh follow-up
uh so on page two
um section two paragraph B
um
I'd like to know how an employer could
initiate payments of wages if they
decline all those three
and then this is my reading of it what I
would do is looking at paragraph B
paragraph B is part of uh
section two so section two starts by
saying if an employer offers its
employees the option of receiving by a
payroll card the employer shall and then
it goes through but I think all of that
is first flowing from the fact that the
employer has elected to offer it via
payroll card I don't view that as
necessarily controlling or altering the
above which is if you go back to
paragraph one on page one
um in a b and c it it introduces those
other methods or modes of payment so
again that's my reading of it if someone
disagrees with the Department's reading
we're happy to hear that but the
Department's reading of this language as
submitted is that those options still
exist really what this is doing is uh
taking away the option of the employee
saying that they want to be paid via a
check or paper check
so similar I think representative
seaworth had spoken to that that again I
think that's the change here is it
saying that they can no longer request a
paper check I do not read this as saying
the employer cannot elect to provide a
paper check or pay via cash on their own
thank you and that leads me to my final
question
same paragraph for uh
if an employee only offers
electronic payments and they don't
provide their
employee doesn't provide their bank
account information I'd like to know how
the employer is supposed to deposit that
money
so again the way if you're in paragraph
B correct so again going up to two it's
saying that if they offer uh if if they
do it by payroll card
they're going to provide the disclosure
and a saying you have to give them all
the disclosures B is saying they can
initiate that but it but it adds in
there that it's after they have failed
to provide so the employee has the
option of saying listen I wanna I want
you to do direct deposit here is my bank
account information if the employee
doesn't do that that's a condition to
then saying okay now they can do the the
payroll card could be forced does that
make sense I apologize I'm not answering
your question but again I'm seeing b as
saying
paying via payroll card one of the
conditions of forcing the payroll card
is first giving them the option to elect
direct deposit if they fail to elect
direct deposit
or if they fail to provide the bank
information so the employer can affect
direct deposit then you could do the
payroll card
final
call I apologize
um so as I read it it looks like the if
the the if the employee just has
electronic means to deposit whether to
use a small company
um
that they're being forced if the
employee could game the system and say
okay well I'm not going to give you my
bank account information I'm going to
make you get payroll cards
because I'm not giving you the option I
don't want to check I don't want cash
they're denying all these so the
employer has we're going to give you
electronic means for your deposit we're
not you can't get the bank account
information now they're forcing me as an
employer to offer to force them to have
a Banky card
even though my say my payroll company
doesn't offer them
I'll admit my first in going through
this I I didn't necessarily take it that
way I would say that to the extent
you're concerned about that and others
are concerned about that perhaps
clarification on that point would would
be needed again the Department's reading
of this is not necessarily saying that
that's
um that it could be forced in that way
um but if if there's a lack of clarity
there then perhaps adjustment should be
made thank you thank you and I'd also
like to follow up on that as I read it
and I like your opinion well we have you
here so this
one thing that and I don't know if it
happens often is where the employer and
the employee do not agree on an
acceptable form of payment
this change in law seems to take away
that
right now the department can say well
you know what if you can't agree on
anything else you have to issue a check
this would seem to take away that
default position
um and that wouldn't just apply in terms
of payroll cards it could be an employer
says well we only pay cash there's no
Bank transfers no checks you can you can
only take cash right now an employee
could say that doesn't work for me but
this would seem to take that away and
leave it at by my reading it's the
employer who has the last word can say
well this is what we offer you choose
from
uh what what we offer you that are valid
uh payments
and that's it you can't ask for
something that we don't want to give you
yes that is how we took the language as
offered as well again to the extent that
folks are saying it's that's not clear
um we perhaps clarification on that
point would be needed
thank you for your input
I see another question
thank you
so in the case of uh
in the case of day workers well you
would have somebody that might work for
a landscape company one day that might
be banging Nails another day
they can't demand cash now under this
they have to the employer is the
employer tell them I'll give it to you
in the debit card
under this this change yes I think the
employer would have the ability to
direct the method of payment in that way
so in the course of the week if I work
for four different people
you know work for contractor a b or c a
d i could have a handful of of debit
cards at the end of the week potentially
yes thank you
any further questions
thank you very much for getting in the
hot seat with us
um that was the final card I had if
there are no other cards
I would take the last
blue sheet
um and while we're getting that the the
sign-ons we had five signed on in
support and one in opposition
Rudy came up while you were out so
however you want to work with that hey I
can start out the numbers you said
uh five support one opposition and once
again nobody signed in on the paper
so with that I will close the hearing on
SB 46 that is our business for today
um in talking with with the chairman I
don't think we have uh
I don't think we're looking for
subcommittees or a lot of detailed work
on this but certainly
everyone has the opportunity to think
about what we did today reread the bills
and and contact the chairman if you have
specific issues
I would expect to hear shortly a
schedule for the executive session I
know he also would like to get a start
on some of our interim study work so if
we're here for the morning for executive
session then maybe we can have some
subcommitting meetings after that we do
need specific authorization from the
speaker to do that ahead of the
um actually getting through all the
Senate bills so that will be TBD as well
if there is anything else that we need
to discuss
I don't see any so we are adjourned for
the day thank you very much for your
attendance and participation
hopefully shut off the system